Moin, Leute.
Oh, ich hab Arsch, ey.
Monka ist...
Ja, 10 Kilometer sind doch immer recht anstrengend, auch wenn man es nicht übertreibt.
Bin gespannt. Mein Ziel ist demnächst ja mal hier eine Runde zu rennen.
11 Kilometer hin, 11 Kilometer zurück.
Mit Pause.
Und was trinken dazwischen.
Boah, mal gucken, wie das wird, ey.
Ich nehme auf jeden Fall das Handy mit, falls ich abgeholt werden muss.
Moin.
Un-S-D-Company.
Pog.
Du siehst Rosebikes. Ja, siehst du richtig.
Ich hab gestern wieder ein Fahrrad.
Gestern wieder ein Fahrrad gekauft.
Gibt's mittlerweile Di2? Das gibt es die ganze Zeit schon.
Was es nicht gibt, ist 1x12 und 2x12 als Di2.
Das ist das Ding. Das ist das, was ich eigentlich haben wollte.
Was ich mir jetzt gekauft habe, ist exakt das gleiche.
Das gleiche Fahrrad, wie ich vorher hatte.
Nur, weil das einzige Lieferbare waren noch 2x11.
Und, ähm, mal gucken, wann das andere rauskommt.
Hat ja auch keinen Sinn, da jetzt ewig zu warten.
Oh Mann, ich bin voll im Arsch, Leute.
Oh, ich seh's gerade.
So, meine Pille nehmen.
Nein, nix Schlimmes.
Vitamine.
Macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Es ist, äh, ich nehme ab und zu so...
Was ist das? Vitamin D?
Ist das, glaube ich?
Was ist das, was man anstatt Sonne nimmt?
Ich nehme da einmal die Woche im Winter eine.
Auch wenn das sehr umstritten ist, ob das überhaupt was bringt.
Schaden wird's wahrscheinlich nix.
Zumal heute viel Sonne war.
Lass mich mal kurz gucken in meinen Fitness-Tracker, wie das heute lief.
Heute war echt nicht schnell und anstrengend.
Heute war das Gegenteil von letzter Woche.
Letzte Woche war übel schnell und nicht so wild.
Ähm.
Und heute war anstrengend und nicht so schnell.
Hier.
Zehn Kilometer.
Eine Stunde vier.
Schatz.
Also mein Garmin-Ding meint, die zweite Hälfte war Minus-Performance-Condition.
Aber das meint es bei der Runde immer, weil die zweite Hälfte geht über eins, zwei
längere Brücken nochmal drüber.
Es geht quasi die zweite Hälfte mehr berghoch als die erste Hälfte und irgendwie denkt
es dann dadurch, dass ich langsamer bin und höheren Puls habe, Minus-Performance-Condition.
Immer die zweite Hälfte von der Runde.
Aber passt schon.
Man, reicht jetzt, ey.
Bestimmt.
Aber es ist trotzdem anstrengend.
Also mein Plan ist tatsächlich, wenn es mal ein bisschen wärmer wird wieder, also wenn
es mal so schönes Wetter, 15 Grad oder so ist.
Sonnenschein, 15 Grad.
Da habe ich mir schon eine Runde ausgeguckt.
Da sind elf Kilometer hin, elf Kilometer zurück.
Von Hanau nach Seligenstadt.
Am Main.
Dem Main-Radweg.
Also das ist kein Main-Radweg.
Main-Weg.
Ja, aber da kann man auch Fahrrad fahren und laufen und so.
Elf Kilometer hin, elf Kilometer zurück.
Mein Plan ist, also ich muss auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Wasser mitnehmen.
So irgendwie mit keinem halben Liter oder so.
Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben.
Ein bisschen was trinken kann.
Ich habe sowas, ich habe sowas Kleines, wie man, wo man sich das so in die, in so eine
Westentasche stecken kann.
Und dann mache ich da kurz Pause.
Hol vielleicht ein Eis oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Und dann, zehn Minuten später, renne ich wieder zurück.
Mal gucken, wie gut das läuft.
Ja, ist es auch.
Ist es auch.
Also ich habe jetzt, ich habe mir gestern das hier gekauft.
Das hier ist mein altes Fahrrad gewesen, das ist das, was kaputt ist wegen Unfall und keiner, also keiner, also alle sagen mit dem Carbon-Rahmen sollte ich nicht mehr auf die Straße gehen, nachdem das einmal vom Auto angefahren wurde.
Das ist das alte, das ist das neue.
Man sieht, es ist also mehr oder weniger das gleiche Fahrrad.
Es ist eins, also es unterscheiden sich ein paar Sachen.
Das ist ein anderer Sattel, aber das ist, wenn mir der neue Sattel nicht gefällt, dann.
Nehme ich einfach den alten wieder, es ist ja der gleiche Rahmen.
Es sind andere Reifen.
Es ist 2x11 Schaltung und hat ein bisschen kleinere Bremsklötze, warum auch immer.
Oder täuscht das auf dem Bild einfach nur, Leute?
Täuscht das oder sind die wirklich ein bisschen kleiner?
Die Bremsbelege da, die Bremsscheiben oder wie das genau, ein bisschen minimal kleiner sind die.
Jaja, also immer.
Ja, da habe ich das gerade drauf stehen.
Ich habe hier so einen, einen Swift, nee, wie heißt das Ding, Wahoo, ein Wahoo Kicker Core, da steht das drauf, da steht hier schräg hinter mir, das alte, weil für Indoor-Fahren ist das noch vollkommen fein.
Das einzige, was ich nach dem Unfall machen musste, man sieht es hier, glaube ich, guckt das Teil hier unten, wo die Schaltung dranhängt, das musste ich austauschen.
Das war nämlich verbogen, deswegen hat das nicht mehr richtig geschaltet.
Das habe ich ausgetauscht und let's go.
Jetzt fährt es wieder.
Ja.
Wobei Prime, Prime bezahle ich auch ganz normal.
Aber ich habe wenige Abos, ich versuche so wenig Abos wie möglich abzuschließen.
Ich mache überall, wenn ich ein Abo abschließe, weil ich irgendwas gucken will oder irgendeine
Dienstleistung, was auch immer, in Anspruch nehme ich.
will. Ich schließe immer das
Abo ab und cancel direkt wieder.
Ich lasse nie Abos laufen.
Abo,
sonst Abo-Falle.
Hat der Rahmen sichtbare
Schäden?
Ab wann fangen bei dir Schäden an?
Der hat ein paar Kratzer.
Ein paar kleine Kratzer. Also er hat keine Risse, keine
offensichtlichen oder so.
Aber sogar der Gutachter sagt
total Schaden.
Also ich glaube denen das mal.
Wahrscheinlich würde nichts passieren.
Aber es wäre doof, wenn ich fahre
und irgendwie ein bisschen härter
irgendwo drauf und dann bricht irgendwas ab
am Rahmen. Das wäre ziemlich
kacke. Ja, immer
direkt Subscription canceln.
Egal ob Netflix oder Onlyfans.
Immer direkt
Subscription canceln.
Natürlich außer bei mir auf Twitch.
So, ich mache mal kurz Package-Updates.
Weil Arch Linux, by the way,
gibt bestimmt neue Packages.
Man muss das ja immer up-to-date
Pleading Edge halten.
Ist ja...
Moin, Calimero.
Was gibt es denn auf
YouTube heute für Empfehlungen?
Warte mal, ich sollte mir doch irgendwas angucken.
Hier. Der Chat hat doch gestern
gesagt, der anzeigende
Hauptmeister soll ich mir angucken.
2 Millionen in 4 Tagen.
Okay, da muss ja echt was her.
Apple TV heute. Braucht es
noch jemand? Die Sache ist
eher umgedreht. Hat das schon
mal jemand, jemals jemand gebraucht?
Das ist die Frage, die ich mir
stelle. Ja, das
wäre halt... Genau. Es passiert dann
im ungünstigsten Moment.
Das passiert nicht so nach dem Motto, ach, ich
fahr jetzt mal los. Ich bin eh noch langsam gerade
aus. Das passiert dann in ungünstigen Sachen
so. In der Kurve
irgendwie über den
Huppel und dann bricht dir irgendwas ab.
Und dann fliegst du aufs Maul.
Azaro, danke
für den Sub. Und dann fliegst du aufs Maul und dann
geht's...
geht irgendwas richtig kaputt. Und nicht nur am
Fahrrad, sondern an dir.
So.
Aber ich find's nice. Ich freu mich
richtig, wenn das neue Fahrrad da ist.
Weil ich hab im Vergleich zum alten Fahrrad
hab ich...
Ich hab knapp 1000 Euro
gespart. Gespart?
Gespart kann man's nicht nennen. Im Endeffekt bin ich
immer noch 2600 Euro los. Aber
das alte Fahrrad hat 3500
gekostet. Das war das hier. Das hat
ja, 3500 gekostet
das alte Fahrrad. Und
ich krieg ja insgesamt von
der Versicherung das jetzt
zurück. Plus Ausfall.
Äh, ja. Und
Anwalt und Gutachten müssen sie auch bezahlen.
Das ist mittlerweile schon bei, glaube
ich, fast 6000 Euro.
Alles zusammen.
Und die haben immer noch
nicht bezahlt. Das wird immer teurer
für die. Jeden Tag, wo die nicht
bezahlen, wird's immer teurer.
Bald ist das... Bald ist das zweite...
ist das neue Fahrrad komplett...
auch, auch quasi, äh...
noch obendrauf, äh...
Nennt sich Girlmath. Warum?
Ist das... Moment!
Ist Girlmath das, was früher
mein Opa Milchmädchenrechnung
genannt hat?
Nennt man das heute Girlmath?
Mein Opa hatte
eh die übelst oldschool
oldschool Wörter. Ich hab's ja letztens
schon gesagt. Er hat ja nie Besteck gesagt. Er hat
immer gesagt Schanzzeug. Und er
hat auch nicht gesagt, jetzt wird's aber
Zeit. Sondern er hat gesagt, es brisiert.
Gut.
Ich mein, wann ist mein Opa auf die
Welt gekommen? Gute Frage.
oder so? Wart mal, mein Opa
wär jetzt... wär jetzt 100.
Über 100 wär der.
Ja, ich glaub 1922
oder so. Wurde mein... ist mein
Opa auf die Welt gekommen. Also sprich, da hat man halt
noch so altertümlich geredet, ja?
Es brisiert
ist noch voll okay. Ernsthaft?
Vielleicht kommt das auch noch aus dem
Krieg. Der hat Besteck
immer Schanzzeug genannt.
Vielleicht ist das so ein
so ein Militär-Slang
gewesen, der irgendwie bei ihm hängen geblieben ist
aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht, vielleicht. Ja, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht kommt das ja von da.
Keine Updates mehr.
Reboot.
Mein Opa war eh der allerbeste Diskutierer.
Ja. Wenn er
Recht hatte, ich glaub, das hab ich schon mal erzählt.
Wenn er Recht hatte,
hat er am Ende von irgendeiner Diskussion
immer gesagt, ja, der Opa
hat für gewöhnlich Recht.
Und wenn
er mich nicht davon überzeugen konnte,
dass er Recht hatte oder er
keinen Bock mehr hatte oder er festgestellt hat,
er hat Mist erzählt, hat er immer
gesagt, ja, ja, du hast Recht
und ich hab meine Ruhe.
Und dann hat er keinen Bock mehr gehabt. Ja, ja, ja.
Also das war
eigentlich unmöglich für meinen Opa
nicht Recht zu haben.
Und zwar bei Design
war das
hardcoded.
Das ging nicht.
Entweder hatte er keinen Bock mehr, hat er nur noch gesagt,
ja, ja, ja, lass mich in Ruhe.
Oder, oder, ja, der Opa hat
für gewöhnlich Recht.
Also eigentlich, du konntest
eigentlich nicht, nicht gewinnen
in dem Sinn bei irgendeiner Diskussion mit meinem Opa.
Aber, und das muss man halt auch,
mein Opa war halt übel,
er war ein übelster Sparfuchs, ja.
Der hat, der hat bei allem gespart.
Ich glaube, das kommt,
das kam bei dem garantiert auch noch
eben aus der Nachkriegszeit.
Ich glaube, wenn du das mal alles mitgemacht hast,
also Krieg und Nachkriegszeit, wenn du das mal
alles mitgemacht hast, da siehst du die Welt ein bisschen anders.
Und
der konnte zum Beispiel
auch nicht langsam essen.
Das war einfach nicht drinne.
Und das kommt garantiert
noch aus dem Krieg und nach dem Krieg.
Der konnte nicht langsam essen. Also ich weiß noch,
der hatte das schon so schön.
Und drei Jahre lang war das noch immer so,
ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß oder nicht,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Ich weiß noch nicht,
aber, und da war,
da ist das anders als damals.
Ich weiß noch nicht,
da war nichts anderes,
aber es gab schon Game Hour,
ja.
Ich weiß nicht,
da gab es noch nicht,
es gab auch schon so viele liebige Spiele,
die mit Spielen und so.
Aber ich weiß nicht,
aber die Spiele,
die waren auch immer so,
naja,
so,
ja,
und, ja,
K.
Also ich weiß nicht,
ob man das auch machen wollte.
Aber, aber das war eigentlich,
rum pilze schinken mais dinger alle mögliche zeug das hat man sich so auf die förmchen gemacht und
rein das ding war mein opfer konnte nicht langsam essen das ging nicht also es war ein ding der
unmöglichkeit für den eineinhalb stunden zu essen das ging nicht das lief immer so ab wir haben den
wir haben abgeholt haben den grill angemacht und noch während der grill aufgeheizt hat hat
er schon angefangen die rohen pilze gurken und käse dinger zu futtern die eigentlich zum grillen
da waren und da habe ich dann immer gemacht ja ob er jetzt war doch mal mach doch mal langsam
machte mal langsam und da meinte er immer so ja ja richtet euch nicht nach mir macht macht ihr
einfach so wie ihr wollt ja und nach einer viertelstunde und vielleicht 12 förmchen war
der fertig und dann hat er eine stunde da gesessen und sich gelangweilt und dann kam es da gab es dann
immer so die diskussionen wie
ja ob er willst du soll man sich zwischendurch heimbringen soll mich heimbringen hat er immer
gesagt nee nee ich richte mich ganz nach euch macht ihr langsam und fünf minuten später hat
er gesagt jetzt wird es aber doch langsam zeit ja willst du heim nee nee ich richte mich ganz
nach euch ja aber langsam könnte man doch mal das war so übelst widersprüchlich immer hatte
eigentlich keinen bock mehr aber wollte halt nicht zu uns sagen auf jetzt macht mal hin
der konnte halt einfach nicht langsam essen das ging nicht und du hast noch einmal als
er als er zu mittagessen da war habe ich gedacht ich musste ihn ich wusste den notarzt rufen weil
er seine spaghetti so schnell gefuttert hat das ist garantiert eine kriegs und nachkriegsgeschichte mit
diesem schnellessen und es gab einmal mit spaghetti war auch da wie gesagt mal ob er
konnte nicht langsam essen und er hat die spaghetti quasi so schnell sich reingestopft dass die die sind
Hals hängen geblieben und auf einmal sitzt
der am Tisch und kriegt keine Luft mehr.
Der sitzt da, ich guck so
zu meinem Opa rüber,
der sitzt da und der sitzt so da
und ich denk mir so, oh scheiße
Alter, ich glaub
der Opa erstickt.
Ich dachte mir so, okay, wenn der jetzt
irgendwie, wenn das noch ein bisschen länger geht,
ich weiß nicht, ich hab übelst Adrenalin
gestoßt, ja, da hab ich gesagt,
ich muss jetzt zum Telefon vorsprinten
und den Notarzt rufen.
Aber irgendwann so nach,
keine Ahnung, nach 5 Sekunden oder so
hat das dann wieder auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Aber da hatte ich
ein bisschen wieder Angst zu tun gekriegt.
Hab gedacht, der erstickt jetzt an der Spaghetti oder so.
Aber der hat
eh super krass gespart
immer, ja. Der hat
beispielsweise auch
im Winter
immer
schon nachmittags
oder irgendwie so,
ich weiß nicht genau wie, die
Heizung ausgeschaltet,
weil das ja Heizkosten spart und
wenn man die Tür zulässt
und einmal richtig geheizt hat und so
und dann reicht das für den Rest des Tages
und so komisches Zeug.
In dem Haus war es immer kalt.
Obwohl der genug Heizung hat.
Es war immer kalt. Im Flur war es kalt.
Also, by the way, das ist das Haus, in dem ich
jetzt wohne hier.
Es war immer kalt.
Im Schlafzimmer war es kalt.
Gut, naja, da ist bei mir auch kühl,
aber nicht kalt. Kalt. In der Küche,
im Flur kalt. Es war überall kalt.
Das Einzige, wo ein bisschen warm war,
war im Wohnzimmer, weil mein Opa halt den ganzen Tag
im Wohnzimmer war, Fernseher geguckt hat,
der hat gerne Kreuzworträtsel
gemacht, sowas halt typisch in Opa-Tätigkeiten
und
es waren sogar
ein paar vom Pflegedienst da, die haben
zu ihm gesagt, ja hier, Herr Opa,
Sie müssen mal ordentlich, ordentlich
warm machen, das ist zu kalt hier.
Es ist im Winter irgendwie 17 Grad,
Erkältung und alles.
Ja,
und meine Vermutung ist,
dass genau das meinem Opa auch
letztendlich zum Verhängnis geworden ist.
Der ist ja schon vor ein paar Jahren
gestorben und zwar an
einer Lungenentzündung,
die wohl dadurch ausgelöst
wurde, dass er Speisereste
in der Lunge hat.
Und das in Kombination mit zu kalter
Umgebung.
Über mehrere Tage
hat sich das dann hingezogen, wurde
immer schlimmer.
Also meine Vermutung
ist, dass
die Kombination
zu krass schnell essen
und zu kalt
permanent in der Wohnung und permanentes
Frieren,
dass das ihm mit zum Verhängnis
geworden ist am Ende.
Man weiß es nie,
kann auch so
irgendwas kriegen ein paar Wochen später,
aber die Kombination passt halt
schon irgendwie.
Aber wisst ihr, eine Sache frage ich
mich ja echt.
Wie hat das eigentlich mein Opa
und meine Oma, wie haben die
das durchgehalten? Wenn ihr dir das
heute teilweise anguckst,
ich bin ja auch so, ich flame ja auch
über alles, ja.
Alles, was nicht irgendwie
so ist, wie mir das gefällt,
wird geflamed.
Und ich frage mich,
wie hat das
meine Oma und mein Opa durchgehalten?
Bei denen war die Welt noch viel
anstrengender.
Und viel
gefährlicher.
Aber die haben eigentlich nie gemeckert.
Und nicht nur ich,
sondern auch generell,
meine Generation und auch
deutlich jüngere Generationen. Und gerade wenn du
auf Twitter und Social Media, wirklich,
es wird über jeden kleinsten
Scheiß gemeckert, als geht's
um Leben oder Tod.
Ich weiß nicht, bei meiner Oma
und meinem Opa ging es wohl wirklich
zwischenzeitlich um Leben und Tod, aber die haben trotzdem nicht
gemeckert.
Ich glaube, das ist es, ja.
Ich glaube, die wissen halt,
gerade noch Zweiter Weltkrieg und danach,
die wussten halt, wie es ist,
wenn es so richtig scheiße ist.
Und danach war alles
toll.
Also alles, was danach kam,
war das Beste.
Ja, dem ist nichts anderes übrig geflammt, ja.
Schon.
So.
Dann lasst uns doch mal schauen,
äh, das wollte ich jetzt nicht auffallen,
was Trende denn auf Shit haben.
Heute.
Die sind nicht mit Twitter aufgewachsen, ja, das stimmt wohl.
Du meinst mit X, ja.
Also mein Opa war,
mein Opa wollte sich drücken,
vor, wie heißt das, vor der
Wehrpflicht oder so.
Oder wie nannte man das im Zweiten Weltkrieg?
Oder ich weiß nicht, ob der sich drücken
wollte, ich kann's schwer sagen,
wie das genau war.
Aber ich weiß, sie sind geflohen,
vor dem Einzug, genau.
Der wollte sich drücken, davor eingezogen zu werden.
Was ich auch voll und ganz verstehen kann,
ich hätte auch keinen Bock, in den Krieg geschickt zu werden.
Also, der, äh, der ist
von daheim weg und, ähm,
ist quasi geflohen
von daheim, dass sie ihn irgendwie nicht einziehen können.
Sie haben ihn aber trotzdem dann
erwischt, irgendwie,
ich kenn die Story, der hat mir das ein paar Mal
erzählt, aber ich krieg's ja bei 13,
die sind zumindest geflohen von daheim
und die wurden dann,
äh, die wurden dann irgendwo
aufgegriffen unterwegs
und halt trotzdem zwangs,
zwangs eingezogen, ja, so wie das
halt in Deutschland gewesen ist, hast du halt gelitten gehabt,
wenn du in dem passenden Alter warst.
Der ist 1922 geboren, glaube,
sprich, der war 20, äh,
oder 18, 18, 20, wann, wann ging der,
1942, oder wann ging der
Zweite Weltkrieg los?
1940, 1942,
1942, oder?
39? Ach,
also der müsste so 18, 19, 20
oder so gewesen sein, mein Opa.
Und, ja,
der, ähm, war in Russland,
am Start, also nicht Frankreich
oder so, der war in Russland
und eins muss man
sagen,
also, das,
das kann man wahrscheinlich, das kann man wahrscheinlich
schwer nachvollziehen, wenn man da nicht dabei war,
aber, der hat nicht,
wie soll man, wie soll man das sagen, also
normalerweise würde ich von ausgehen, ja, wenn du, wenn du da
im Krieg gewesen bist und das war der Feind
und so, dann findest du die dein Leben lang kacke.
Aber mein Opa hat nie schlecht
über irgendwelche Russen geredet.
Also,
der fand russische, wie soll man sagen,
russische Musik, russische
Kulturs und solche, fand er super
interessant, auch nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Also,
mein Opa fand
die russische Seite viel cooler,
quasi, als die Amis.
Ähm,
die Amis mochte er überhaupt nicht.
Bis, bis,
bis zum Schluss, die Amis mochte er gar nicht.
Und das, obwohl er im Krieg
in Russland war.
Mit Sicherheit, mit Sicherheit hat er Angst
vor den Russen gehabt und die Russen vor den Deutschen.
Das war, das war ja damals,
die, die wollten ja beide nicht.
Die hatten, ich glaube, das lag bestimmt
auch daran, dass beide Seiten
eigentlich, wie soll man sagen, auf persönlicher
Ebene halt so gar nichts
gegeneinander hatten.
Die mussten sich halt umbringen gegenseitig.
Es ist nicht so, dass die sich
nicht leiden konnten oder so.
Im Vorfeld. Die kannten sich ja gar nicht.
Die mussten sich halt killen gegenseitig.
Zumindest mein Opa war übelst, ähm,
lucky, zumindest,
was das angeht. Weiß nicht, ob man das
glücklich nennen kann, aber irgendwo,
irgendwo schon,
der war, wie gesagt, der war
in Russland.
Und von
seiner, wie nannt man das, Abteilung,
Kompanie, was auch immer,
waren sie, also der Gruppe, frag mich nicht,
keine Ahnung, ich weiß ja auch noch von dem, was
mein Opa erzählt hat,
waren sie irgendwie, glaube ich, 15 Leute und nur zwei
davon haben sie überlebt.
Einer davon mein Opa. Und mein
Opa hat das Ganze überlebt.
Oder ich weiß nicht, 15 Leute oder irgendwie so.
Mein Opa hat das überlebt,
weil er,
sie haben ihm, also
das hat er mir ein paar Mal so erzählt,
ähm, sie sollten irgendwelche, äh, Bunker
oder Häuser stürmen. Und am Anfang
waren sie 15.
Und am Ende waren sie nur noch zwei
Überlebende.
Und
sein Boss
hat halt immer wieder gesagt, die sollen
quasi immer wieder neu angreifen,
bis dann halt am Ende nur noch zwei Leute übrig waren.
Und bei dem letzten Angriff
hat irgendwie mein Opa eine Granate
abbekommen, die ihm
den Fußzeh abgesprengt hat.
Und danach wurde er ins Krankenhaus
gebracht und dann heim.
Und insofern war er
lucky, dass er das überlebt hat.
Und, sag mal, eine relativ leichte
Verletzung nur davon getragen hat.
Und dementsprechend
dann aus dem Krieg weg war.
Das ist aber schon krass, wenn du jetzt
überlegst. Und, also, man muss
halt echt sagen, der hat sich
das nicht anmerken lassen. Und,
als ich klein war, habe ich das auch nicht
sozusagen, nicht wirklich realisiert.
Aber das muss schon echt traumatisierend
gewesen sein, ja.
Man hat das damals,
gerade bei der Generation von meinem
Opa, hat man das alles, glaube ich,
noch nicht so ernst genommen.
Ja, da gibt es ja Berichte von Leuten, so nach
dem Motto, die in der Kneipe gesessen haben, es hat
irgendwo die Tür geknallt, sie sind unter den Tisch gesprungen
und sowas. Da hat man so ausgelacht.
Ich glaube, das wurde da halt
auch überhaupt nicht ernst genommen.
Und er hat mir da,
da habe ich schon so ein paar Dinger erzählt,
wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, okay,
das ist nicht ohne. Ja, hat auch
gemeint, bei einem ihrer
Manöver,
die sie da gemacht haben
im Militär, ist neben
ihnen irgendwie Artillerie eingeschlagen
und
er hat es eigentlich nur knallen gehört, er ist
nebenhin gesprungen
und als er
die Augen aufgemacht hat,
hat er gesehen, dass der Typ, der neben ihm
stand, vorher,
der stand nicht mehr bei ihm,
der hing halb durchgesplittet über
einem Baum, über
einem Baumast
im Baum.
Das hat er mir ein paar mal erzählt und ich-
also ich glaube, da hast du echt Dinger gesehen
im zweiten Weltkrieg, die hast du nie wieder vergessen.
Und genau das war damals nicht so ein Thema.
Ja?
Heute ist das alles deutlich besser untersucht
und ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Leute
damals komplett traumatisiert waren und gar nicht mehr...
mehr normal leben konnten für für jahrzehnte ohne irgendwie ansatzweise die
unterstützung bekommen zu haben die sie gebraucht hätten
da wurde die waren ja übelst am ende des krieges habe ich mal habe ich mal ein
ich habe ich meinen doku darüber gesehen am ende des krieges bestand die deutsche
armee zum großteil aus super jungen und älteren leuten also sprich alles was
bis dahin nicht am start war der rest ist war verletzt oder tot
du hattest du alles ältere und super jungen ja das mit essen hat mir die oma
auch erzählt ja also wir können schon echt froh sein dass unser einziges
problem ist heute auf twitter darüber zu flamen ob einer im stream irgendeinen
scheiß erzählt hat oder nicht ja ja da gab es verschiedene umschreibungen für
das war damals ja auch gar nicht wir waren gar nicht großartig untersucht
also ich finde es wird ein bisschen viel geflammt allgemein
was man da
nicht vergessen oder ich habe schon oft gesagt im stream eigentlich können wir
ganz froh sein dass wir in der heutigen zeit leben in der wir leben es ist
sicherlich nicht alles toll ja und es gibt sicherlich noch mehr als
genug was man verbessern kann und wenn man so ein bisschen antrieb hat und so
ein bisschen weltverbesserer machen will why not ja vielleicht kommt ja was bei
raus aber unterm strich muss man sagen wir leben heute in der zeit ich meine
jetzt hier wir an unserem ort nicht überall in der welt gibt ja genug wo das
noch nicht so ist wir können uns persönlich so
frei entfalten wie noch nie vorher ohne dass man sich irgendeinen scheiß von
anderen leuten anhören muss leute serious wie wenn ich mich jetzt im
stream im stream stellen würde hier und sagen leute übrigens bei der ich bin
schwul kapper breit da würdet ihr sagen ja max who cares
natürlich hast du immer noch ein paar die dann rumflamen würden oder ein paar
die ein beleidigen müssten deswegen gibt es immer irgendwelche às zu 99% geht das
den leuten am arsch vorbei
Und das ist doch nice.
Heute wirst du auch nicht mehr
Shep angeguckt, wenn du mit 35
Jahren vorm PC sitzt
und Computerspiele noch spielst.
Das ist heute, wie soll man sagen,
Mainstream. Also kannst
dich heute mehr oder weniger
so frei entfalten wie noch nie
zuvor. Und das ist doch auch nice.
Gerade wenn
du hier auf Twitter so rumscrollst,
da denkst du ja irgendwie echt, die Welt geht unter.
Eins ist schlimmer als das andere.
Der eine Streamer streamt
Hogwarts Legacy. Oh nein, die Welt geht unter.
Die sind immer so am eskalieren
wegen jedem Furz, Alter.
Ich sag ja nicht, dass es nichts zu verbessern gibt.
Aber insgesamt
ist es
heutzutage wirklich nice.
Zumindest hier
in unseren breiten Graden
bei uns.
Ich find's hier echt nicht verkehrt.
Twitter.
Ja, ich hab mein Twitter
umgestellt auf Andorra.
Seitdem ist es nicht mehr ganz so schlimm.
Wobei ich immer noch ab und zu in die
deutschsprachigen Trends reingucke
und mir da immer an den Kopf fassen muss, was da für
eine Scheiße teilweise trendet.
Das stimmt, da hast du recht.
Ja, das hast du recht.
Ich find das übrigens auch
blöd, generell Leute immer mit sowas
abzustempeln. Oder es gibt ja,
guck mal, es gibt zwei Sachen.
Es gibt die einen, für die ist alles,
was
von der anderen Seite Gutmenschen,
und dann hast du die andere Seite,
für die sind alles Schlafschafe und sowas.
Ich glaube, das ist in der Realität
selten schwarz und weiß.
Und das in einer Person.
Also,
es ist selten so, dass
das, wie soll man sagen, dass man
einer Person in allen ihren Sachen
so zustimmt.
Viele Leute können auch
total widersprüchliche Sachen
denken.
Wo ich denke,
hey, wie passt das jetzt eigentlich?
Und, ja, das hast du aber halt
auch dank Twitter
oder generell dank
verschiedener Blasen im Internet,
dass sich eigentlich nur
so Gleichgesinnte immer gegenseitig
Circle-Jerken
und sich
gegenseitig da anstacheln.
Und nachdem die ja
mehr oder weniger permanent
sich mit Gleichgesinnten umgeben,
sind die auch der Meinung,
dass die gesamte Welt das gefälligst,
so zu sehen hat, wie sie.
Ja. Und das ist,
und das ist auch, da gebe ich dir recht,
das ist auch eine Einstellung, die enorm zugenommen hat.
Die meisten Leute haben
zu den meisten Themen
gar keine spezielle Meinung, weil die es überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Das geht ihnen am Arsch vorbei.
Und wenn das Erste,
womit sie in Kontakt kommen,
irgendwelche aggressiven Twitterer sind,
die ihnen erzählen würden,
die ihnen erzählen, dass sie scheiße sind,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
nicht dafür, dass die Leute über irgendwas nachdenken
und sich überlegen, ja, okay, hm,
ist ja was dran, sondern du sorgst eigentlich eher dafür,
dass du noch mehr Leute produzierst,
die gegen dich sind.
Aber das kriegen sie auf Twitter wunderbar hin.
Oder generell nicht nur.
Also Twitter ist halt so dieses
Bubble-Circle-Jerk-Ding schlechthin.
Und das hast du auch an vielen,
vielen Bereichen, das stimmt.
Wenn man nicht für irgendwas ist, bist du automatisch dagegen.
Vielen Leuten ist
das meiste vollkommen egal.
Die sind mit sich selbst,
mit sich selbst beschäftigt.
Und ich glaube, viele Leute auf Twitter
wären tatsächlich auch mal ganz gut beraten,
wenn sie sich ein bisschen mehr um ihren eigenen Scheiß kümmern würden.
Anstatt allen anderen immer zu erzählen,
wie moralisch das,
unmoralisch das jetzt ist, oder
wie sie Bescheid wissen und die anderen nicht.
Es ist alles ziemlich für'n Arsch, wenn ihr dir das auf Twi-
Also wenn man wirklich
Twitter ernsthaft konsumiert
und sich diese ganzen Tags anguckt
und schaut, was da drunter so abgeht und das wirklich
sozusagen alles für
bare Münze nimmt
und sich da reinsteigert,
da drehst du irgendwann am Rad.
Da wirst du verrückt.
Twitch ist teilweise auch nicht...
Nee, eigentlich so gut wie jede öffentliche Plattform
ist da nicht, ist da nicht wirklich besser.
Das Ding ist halt,
die Welt ist selten schwarz und weiß.
Es ist meistens irgendwo so im Graubereich dazwischen.
Einzelpersonen können übelst widersprüchliche Meinungen
zu unterschiedlichen Themen haben.
Wo man sich denkt immer so, hä, wie passt das überhaupt zusammen?
Machst du lieber Smalltalk oder Realtalk?
Am liebsten talk ich gar nicht mit Leuten,
weil mir die meisten Leute auf den Sack gehen.
So ein Ding, was mir auf Social Media immer ein bisschen auf den Keks geht, ist
nicht so sehr, dass die Leute da ihre Meinung schreiben
oder andere flamen oder so,
sondern dass sie der Meinung sind,
dass sie die komplette, wie nennt man das so,
so diese komplette Deutungshoheit haben.
So nach dem Motto,
ich entscheide jetzt,
was richtig und falsch ist.
Und sie dann aber auch der Überzeugung sind,
die gesamte Welt muss das so sehen wie sie,
weil sie die ultimative Entscheidungsinstanz sind,
die das jetzt entschieden haben,
das was gut oder das was schlecht ist.
Und wenn du das nicht so siehst,
dann musst du nicht einfach nur auf Twitter geflamed werden,
dann musst du nach Möglichkeit so fertig gemacht werden,
dass dich dein Arbeitgeber rausschmeißt.
Und wenn du das gut findest,
dann kannst du mit Circle Jerken in der Twitter-Bubble.
Oder umgedreht.
Ah, je nachdem, bei welcher Seite du bist.
Das ist halt richtig krass geworden,
die letzten Jahre über.
Es ist nicht einfach nur mehr Meinungsverschiedenheit,
es ist sehr viel Zerstörungswut auf beiden Seiten.
Oder was heißt auf beiden?
Es gibt nicht nur zwei Seiten,
auf allen Seiten dabei,
sehr viel Zerstörungswut.
Es geht nicht darum, den anderen zu erzählen,
dass sie falsch liegen,
es geht darum, den anderen zu erzählen,
dass sie quasi falsch liegen
und dadurch quasi nahezu unmenschlich sind
und man sie fertig machen kann,
bis aufs Blut.
Das ist Social Media auf Twitter in vielen Fällen.
Und das ist halt echt was, wo ich mir denke,
das artet immer mehr aus.
Das hast du bei verschiedenen Sachen gesehen,
die letzten Jahre über.
Ich denke, die Hogwarts-Legacies-Sache war ein gutes Beispiel für,
das hat sich ja Wochen und Monate fast hingezogen.
Und da wurde sich das Todes geflamed,
es wurde sich angezeigt gegenseitig.
Es wurde versucht,
das Leben von Leuten zu ruinieren
mit Anrufen bei Arbeitgebern.
Und ey, das ist nicht mehr normal, Leute,
was da abgeht.
Naja, warum nicht?
Letztendlich ist, egal was du gewählt hast,
fast alles Kacke.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich die FDP gewählt,
das letzte Mal.
Das ist aber auch kein Geheimnis,
weil das habe ich das letzte Mal
ja auch schon erzählt im Stream.
Aber wir wissen doch,
der Markt regelt das schon.
Ich würde nicht mal sagen,
dass es jeder tut,
aber die, die es tun, machen,
das in einer enorm penetranten Art und Weise.
Wisst ihr?
Und das ist das Letzte,
was ich dazu sagen will.
Ich habe, ähm,
wir in Frieden,
ne, das nächste Mal wähle ich nicht FDP,
weil die wahrscheinlich nicht über 5% packen.
Wie gesagt, ich finde,
Social Media an sich
und das anderer Meinung sein
ist eigentlich was,
wo ich unterm Strich sagen würde,
bringt die Leute voran,
bringt die Sache vorwärts.
Aber es geht ja nicht darum,
anderer Meinung zu sein,
um vielleicht darüber zu diskutieren
oder sich ein bisschen zu flattern.
Oder sich ein bisschen zu flamen
oder sowas.
Ich finde,
die Zerstörungswut gegenseitig
ist einfach viel zu groß da mittlerweile.
Ich mit der Musik im Hintergrund los.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Alles klar.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung.
Es ist glücklicherweise
auch noch ein bisschen hin.
Bis zur,
bis zur nächsten Wahl.
Ich, mal ein Beispiel.
Okay, wir machen mal,
wir machen mal ein Beispiel dazu,
wo, wo du Twitter
komplett mit auf die Palme bringen kannst.
Stell euch mal vor,
das ist jetzt,
ich stelle euch mal vor,
ich würde theoretisch posten auf Twitter.
Angenommen,
es wäre jetzt Bundestagswahl.
Und ich würde,
ich würde auf Twitter so was posten wie
Leute geht wählen.
Das ist richtig.
Wählt, was ihr wollt.
Selbst wenn es die AfD ist.
Stell euch mal vor,
ich würde das jetzt twittern.
Dann würde auf der einen Seite
komplett eskaliert werden.
Wie kann das sein?
Die würden dann rein interpretieren.
Max empfiehlt,
Leute in der AfD zu wählen.
Die würden komplett,
die würden komplett Trigger,
die würden komplett eskalieren.
Ja, aber die andere Seite,
die andere Seite würde auch komplett eskalieren.
So nach dem Motto.
Guckt mal hier,
der Max dreht das so,
dass er sich dem Mainstream schon so anbiedert.
Das würden alle,
es würden alle beide Seiten voll eskalieren.
Das heißt,
du hast eigentlich gar keine Chance,
wenn du da irgendwas sagst in der Richtung.
Alle beiden Seiten würden voll ausrasten.
Livestreams Fails ist informiert.
Die würden alle ausrasten.
Ja, das ist super,
ist super getriggert.
Alle wieder,
wenn du sowas posten würde.
Nein, den anderen wird das,
dem wird das auch nicht gefallen,
weil die Pro-AfD Leute würden diese,
würde diese,
wie soll man sagen,
dieses,
würde meinen Post überhaupt nicht gefallen,
weil das für die viel zu hinten rum wäre.
Die würden dann sagen,
ja, guck mal,
der Max würde das ja gerne machen,
aber er traut sich nicht,
das öffentlich zu sagen.
Also eigentlich macht er das ja schlecht.
Da würden sie,
es würden sich,
es würden sich beide sein ultra getriggert fühlen.
Oder noch machen wir es anders.
Ich müsste,
ich müsste den Twitter Post anders formulieren.
Ich müsste den Twitter Post anders formulieren.
Dann,
dann würden,
dann würden sich definitiv beide Seiten getriggert fühlen.
Ich müsste schreiben,
morgen ist Bundestagswahl,
geht alle wählen,
das ist wichtig.
Wählt,
was ihr wollt,
selbst wenn es die AfD ist.
Obwohl das für mich nichts wäre.
So müsste ich das schreiben.
Und das würde beide Seiten,
das Todes triggern.
Die einen würden sagen,
oh hier,
hier Nazi-Kram,
hier voll empfiehlt die AfD.
Und die anderen würden sagen,
guck mal hier,
wie verklausuliert er das wieder schreibt.
Und eigentlich will er sich dann nur anbiedern der anderen Seite.
Und das schlecht,
das würde beides sein.
Brutals triggern.
Und das ist halt das Ding so auf Twitter.
Deswegen ist das Beste,
was man machen kann,
bei solchen Sachen gar nichts dazu sagen.
Was ja übrigens auch laut Umfragen im Trend liegt.
Aber,
wenn man sich Umfragen anguckt,
dann sagt ein nicht,
und ich weiß nicht,
wie viel es genau sind,
deswegen sage ich jetzt keine Prozentsatz,
ein nicht unerheblicher Teil der Leute,
sagt,
sie haben das Gefühl,
öffentlich nicht das,
was sie denken,
sagen zu können.
Was sicherlich auch ein bisschen mit diesem Fertiggemache
von allen Seiten,
egal was du sagst,
liegt.
Naja.
Aber ich werde das auch nicht posten,
auf Twitter zur nächsten Bundestagswahl.
Das war jetzt nur ein Beispiel,
ja.
Und es würde beides sein,
ultra triggern.
So.
Das würde auch beides,
das würde auch,
das ist auch nicht schlecht,
das würde auch Leute ultra,
das würde,
wisst ihr,
was man daran sieht ist,
dass das würde beide Seiten,
gleichermaßen triggern.
Das ist halt so das Widersprüchliche.
Dabei postest du,
von der Aussage her,
noch was relativ Normales.
Geht wählen,
ja.
Genau.
Eigentlich das,
was man,
den Rest muss man weglassen.
Aber das war jetzt ja nur ein Beispiel für,
wie man eine Sache posten kann,
was die komplett entgegengesetzten Lager triggern würde.
Aber denkst du,
es ändert was,
wenn du die Grünen sagst,
pff.
Wenn ich das genauso schreiben würde,
hm,
ja,
nee,
das würde wahrscheinlich nicht viel ändern.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich würde,
wahrscheinlich würde das nicht viel ändern.
Wenn ich,
wenn ich schreiben würde auf Twitter,
ähm,
Leute,
morgen ist Bundestagswahl,
geht wählen,
es ist wichtig,
äh,
geht wählen,
was ihr wollt,
selbst wenn es die Grünen sind,
auch wenn das nicht so mein Ding ist.
Also,
wenn ich quasi einfach nur,
das würde,
das würde wahrscheinlich wenig ändern.
Das würde wahrscheinlich auch beide Seiten ultra triggern.
Wahrscheinlich,
es ist sogar fast egal,
ja.
Ja,
das,
wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich würde das schon reichen,
ne.
Ich bin übrigens mal sehr gespannt,
was,
äh,
Bundestagswahl 2025?
2025?
Ja,
Ende des Jahres,
irgendwann 2025.
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
was da rauskommt.
Oh nein,
ich habe echt keine Ahnung,
wen ich wählen werde.
Die FDP werde ich nicht mehr wählen,
weil ich nicht glaube,
dass es die FDP,
zumindest,
wenn es so weitergeht,
wie von den Umfragen aktuell,
irgendwie noch über 5% kommt.
4%?
Nee,
5%,
oder?
Ja,
ja,
die werden das,
die werden das wahrscheinlich
nicht schaffen.
Dementsprechend kein Plan.
Jetzt geht es schon im Chat ab,
ey.
So,
wir gucken mal,
was so trendet
auf GitHub.
Ach ja.
Und wisst ihr,
wo ich auch sehr gespannt drauf bin?
Was nächstes Jahr rauskommt,
nee,
nicht nächstes Jahr,
dieses Jahr ist es ja!
Ende diesen Jahres
in den USA,
was da rauskommt.
Da bin ich mal,
bin ich mal sehr gespannt.
Da haben sie ja
die Auswahl quasi
zwischen einem Opa
einem Opa und dem anderen Opa.
Die sind ja witzigerweise
gar nicht so unterschiedlich alt.
Ich glaube,
Trump ist doch auch
irgendwie nur vier oder fünf Jahre oder so jünger
als der Beiden. Die sind doch,
die sind beide viel zu alt
eigentlich. Oder fragst du
normalerweise, sitzt du da als Rentner irgendwo,
guckst du am Fenster und
meckerst über die Leute, die Fußball spielen
im Garten. Das ist
eine schöne Aussage und weißt du was?
Selbst wenn du das auf Twitter
posten würdest, wären
alle ultra getriggert.
Weil du,
weil du
die ihrer Meinung nach
Bösen nicht ausgeschlossen hast
in deinem Post. Da werden auch beide Seiten
getriggert.
Da werden auch alle sein.
Deswegen, es ist auf Twitter enorm
schwierig. Du kannst eigentlich dich nicht zu diesem
Thema äußern, ohne dass du
irgendeine Seite triggerst.
Und es gibt nicht nur zwei Seiten, es gibt
nahezu unendlich viele.
Es ist teilweise auch sehr widersprüchlich,
was die gleichen Leute posten.
Also was bei den Amis rauskommt, bin ich
auch mal sehr gespannt.
Vielleicht kriegen wir dann wieder solche
lustigen Sachen wie, zu Corona
muss man Desinfektionsmittel
trinken und sowas.
Ich meine, für den Entertainment-Faktor
war das schon nicht schlecht. Muss man
zugeben. Also
ich fand den Entertainment-Faktor von außen
betrachtet, zur Trump-Zeit
deutlich nicer
als jetzt. Das Einzige,
Witzige, was ich bisher
mitbekommen habe vom Biden, ist
diese Zusammenschnitte, die es auf YouTube
gibt, wo er seinen Text vergisst bei irgendwelchen
Reden.
Oder wo er, was
letztens den Präsident verwechselt hat
von Venezuela und Mexiko oder
irgendwie sowas. Aber das
muss ich sagen, der Entertainment-Faktor war bei
Trump schon höher. Oder Mexiko
und Ägypten.
Der Entertainment-Faktor war schon höher.
Ja, so genau
bin ich da nicht drin, bei den Amis, was da abgeht.
So, dann
lass uns doch mal gucken, was auf GitHub so
trendet. Okay, also.
Ach ja, das sind die, die
Nintendo verklagt hat.
Oder verklagen will, verklagt hat.
Die haben anscheinend
einiges an Zuspruch bekommen
diese Woche.
Viele Leute, das ist halt das Ding bei solchen
Sachen, Nintendo, gell? Auch viele
Leute, die Yuzu
nicht kennen, wurden jetzt durch
die News, Nintendo verklagt Yuzu,
zufällig darauf aufmerksam. Da gibt
es ja einen Nintendo-Switch-Emulator.
Leute, ist ja gut im
Chat jetzt.
Man kann sich, ich gebe
euch nochmal einen Tipp-Chat, damit das Ganze
jetzt nicht ausartet. Man kann
sich auch darauf verständigen,
dass man einfach unterschiedlicher Meinung ist
bei irgendeinem Thema und dann ist gut.
Erstmal ein Mirror ziehen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das
gelöscht wird. Außerdem gibt es so viele
Kopien davon. Lässiger Lord, danke für
den Sub. Außerdem gibt es so viele Kopien
davon. Glaub nicht, dass das ein Problem
ist, dass das... Ich kann mir auch nicht
vorstellen, dass Nintendo damit Erfolg
hat. Oh, Michael,
5 Speljahre, du hast ja gestern subscribt, hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Schön, wenn du den Sub...
Nice.
Okay, das ist
AI. Über AI überspringen wir.
AI.
Ein C++-Interface
für irgendwas. Allein schon, weil es C++ ist.
Gucken wir uns das in der Nähe an.
Ähm...
Absolut...
Keine Ahnung, was
das sein soll.
China-Chinesen-Kram auf jeden Fall.
China...
AI-Sun. Ah, ja.
Ja, mhm, mhm, mhm. Okay, alles
klar. Ich hab
seriously absolut keinen blassen Schimmer, was
das sein soll.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Ist ein riesiger Leak
an chinesischen Hacker-Tools. Aha.
Chinese Hacker-Mans.
Das hab ich mir schon mal angeguckt. Das war
glaube ich ganz nice.
Activation-Skripts.
Ah, mhm, mhm, alles klar.
Was das ist?
Das ist...
Web-App for
Watching Movies Easily.
Ich vermute mal, dass es ein Web-Interface
ist, wo du verschiedene Plugins hast,
über welche Wege du Movies
gucken kannst. Hier.
From Third-Party-Providers.
Diese Third-Party-Providers
müssen nicht zwangsläufig legal
sein, wo... Also nein, die Third-Party-Providers
sind wahrscheinlich legal, aber die
Quellen, woher diese
Sachen gezogen werden, die müssen nicht zwangsläufig
legal sein. Die Activation-Skripts
nutzt Microsoft selber, ja, dann ist gut.
Mario Kart 3.js.
Da hab ich ein Video zu gesehen.
Irgendjemand hat Mario Kart in JavaScript gebaut.
Es ist ein bisschen milchig
alles, oder? Und die
Controls sind weird.
Und da hat die Strecken...
Okay, unegliche Animationen.
Ein bisschen sehr blurry
ist hier alles.
Chat, ich hab Mario Kart schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr gespielt.
Ist das eine offiziell importierte
Strecke? Oder hat er
die gebaut?
Dark Reader, meinst du, ist das?
Ich hab hier gar kein Dark Reader an.
In Chrome.
Wenn das Mario Kart Tour
ist, dann hat er die Strecke
etwa aus Android
extrahiert, oder hat er die nachgebaut?
Wie gesagt, ich hab weder
Mario Kart Tour noch in letzter Zeit
Mario Kart gespielt.
Zumindest hat er nur die Geometrie-Sachen
importiert und keine Animationen.
Und so. Aber es ist schon cool, dass
sowas mit JavaScript funzt, oder?
Ich würde gerne mein Item einsetzen,
wenn ich wüsste, wie...
Wow. Keine... Oh.
Leute.
Die Collision ist kaputt.
Okay, da sind wir wieder.
Ah, so löst
mein Item sein, okay.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die Strecke lang geht,
ehrlich gesagt. Außen?
Hier irgendwo? Ne.
Chat, wo geht die Strecke lang?
Hier nicht.
Wann kommt die Klage von Nintendo?
Ne, allein schon,
allein schon, dass dort
irgendwie Mario importiert wurde,
ist... Anzeige ist raus.
Ich hab seriously keine Ahnung, wo es lang geht.
Guck mal, der hat sogar
die Turbo-Mechanik drin.
Ich mein, die Steuerung, die Steuerung
ist schon mies, ja, im Vergleich zum Original.
Aber für JavaScript,
und guck mal auch, wie flüssig und nice das im Browser läuft.
Ich glaub, das ist alles,
was von der Strecke verfügbar ist, kann das sein?
Ne.
Naja. Mario Kart CS.
Aber cool, dass sowas in JavaScript mittlerweile tut.
Hab ich eigentlich den
Stream-Titel ordentlich geändert?
Aufwachen-Stream, ja.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
AI? AI?
Wahrscheinlich auch AI?
Java-Kram?
React-Zeug?
Okay, ich verstehe null,
was das sein soll.
Ein intuitives Squee?
Für Glee-Glee-Gen?
That uses Comfy-UI in the back-
What?
Gen klingt schon mal irgendwie nach AI.
AI-Zeug, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist cool.
Hier hab ich auch schon die ein oder anderen Sachen
drinne gefunden.
Public, also List of Public UIs.
Da hab ich Geocoding-Sachen
mal drinne gefunden, ja.
Reverse Geocoding.
Und ich hab irgendeinen Service benutzt,
MP.
Irgendwas mit Proton oder so hier.
Also damit kann man beispielsweise Straßen zu Koordinaten auflösen
und Koordinaten zu Straßen und sowas.
Also ich kann quasi sagen,
wo befinde ich mich an dieser Koordinate?
Und dann sagt er mir,
ah, sie befinden sich Frankfurt
Zeil 5 oder so.
Da hab ich irgendeinen Service benutzt,
der nannte sich Photon oder so, glaube ich.
Hab ich auch.
Auch hier.
Ich glaub sogar aus dieser Liste gefunden.
Äh, AI.
AI.
Nicht AI.
Okay, diese Woche ist ja gefühlt 90% AI.
Okay, lass mal kurz gucken,
was in...
Was uns die Sharp trendet.
Wahrscheinlich Yuzu ganz oben.
Diese Woche.
Was?
Okay.
Noch einen anderen Nintendo Switch Emulator trendet.
AI.
ASP.NET Core trendet.
Zu Recht.
Bestes Web Framework. Backend-technisch. Ever.
Gehört Blazer eigentlich offiziell zu ASP.NET Core?
Bin ja kein großer Blazer-Fan.
Maui? Dass das trendet, versteh ich nicht.
Ah, ne.
Und das ist noch zu viel.
Ich mag Maui überhaupt nicht.
China-Chinesen.net Guide.
Jellyfin.
Der Billy Billy Downloader.
Billy Billy ist das China-YouTube, gell?
Fluent UI Blazer.
Okay, wenn man will, dass seine Blazer-Seiten hässlich aussehen,
dann kann man das verwenden.
Leute, ich hab keinen Darkreader.
Alter.
Wenn man will,
dass seine Webseite aussieht,
wie die hässliche Microsoft-Documentation-Seite,
dann kann man das verwenden.
Boah, ist das eklig, Alter.
Wollt ihr wirklich,
dass eure Webseite so aussieht?
Seriously?
Hab ich jetzt Darkreader an oder aus?
Okay, es sieht ja noch hässlicher aus.
Ne, jetzt hab ich's.
Moment, jetzt ist es an, jetzt ist es aus.
Wenn man ernsthaft, dass seine Webseite so aussieht,
ja?
Ich find, das sieht mies aus.
Gibt es, kann man noch
Light-Theme machen?
Light?
Okay, Light, sieht das nur halbwegs brauchbar aus.
Haben die so was?
Wie ein Date-Picker oder sowas?
Picker?
Naja.
Aber hier ist was, Date-Time.
Okay, Leute, ich geb zu,
es sieht nicht richtig scheiße aus,
aber ich find nicht, dass es gut aussieht.
Ich mag die,
das Feeling davon nicht.
Wie benutzt man das?
Ist das, das ist ein,
ja, das ist reines Blazer-Gedöns.
Okay, jetzt muss ich mal gucken,
wie machen die,
wie machen die die Progress-Bar?
Das ist natürlich schon ganz interessant.
Ob die nen Progress
nehmen oder nen selbstgestyltes
Element.
Sie nehmen ein selbstgestyltes Element,
ja?
Was ich sehr gut finde.
Ja, ja, ja, es ist kein,
es ist kein restylter Progress-Bar,
was besser, was, was, was,
ähm, auch nicht so gut wäre.
Also, dann machen die's richtig.
Also, mir gefällt das Feeling hiervon gar nicht.
Es, es sieht aus,
wie die Microsoft-Documentation-Seite
und mit der verbinde ich nichts Gutes.
Einmal nen Input, Form und Inputs.
Time, Time-Picker,
ah, den haben wir schon.
Switch, so wie's sein muss.
Gibt's einen Pin-Input?
Äh, das ist mir zu,
zu Windows-mäßig hier
das Ganze.
Da hab ich, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Was für nen Ding?
RPG-Framework.
Ah,
für Weeb-Games.
Ne.
Naja, bisschen, vielleicht.
Welcher UI-Style
ist gerade in?
Also, was man oft
sieht, leider, ist Material-Design-Style,
der mir persönlich
gar nicht gefällt.
Material-Design-Style
sieht man dank Google und Android
relativ oft.
Ansonsten,
welcher Chat, da seid ihr vielleicht
die ganzen
Web-Entwicklungsleute hier und
Web-Designer-Leute.
Welcher UI-Style ist gerade angesagt?
Also, meinem Eindruck nach gibt es immer noch
viel zu viel Material-Design
und ein paar, die gerne aussehen wollen wie Apple.
Manch einer hat auch noch
Bootstrap, was einfacher aussieht wie Bootstrap.
Welcher, welcher Style
ist gerade so im Trend?
Ich kann's euch nicht sagen.
Ich bin ja auch nicht der
Style-Meister, was Webseiten angeht.
Ich kann auch nur sagen, was ich höre.
Habt ihr Beispiele für Material-Design?
Ja, habe ich.
Für schlechtes Material-Design.
Da muss ich immer den Date-Picker nehmen.
Ich finde das so abartig.
Ja, das hier ist auch material...
Und mit der 24-Stunden-Uhr ist es noch schlimmer.
Guckt euch das mal an, Alter.
Meine Güte, ey. Ich finde das so...
Das ist der Design-Horror schlechthin.
Dieser Date... Dieser Time-Picker.
Dieser Standard-Material-Design-Time-Picker.
Du findest das clever?
Ernsthaft? Ich finde das richtig
eklig.
Das ist so ein typisches Ding
für...
Es funktioniert auf Mobile halbwegs,
aber auf dem Desktop
ist es einfach kacke.
Das ist richtig widerlich, ja.
Das ist Material... Das ist eines meiner Lieblings-
Negativ-Beispiele, warum Material-Design
suckt. Ansonsten,
was Material-Design ausmacht,
sind oftmals diese...
Diese so runden
Buttons mit sehr kontrastreichen
Farben, die man aus
Android-Anwendungen kennt.
Wisst ihr diese... Tja, schwer zu sagen.
Viele Android-Anwendungen haben unten rechts
einen sehr kontrastreichen Button.
Einen sehr kontrastreichen, runden Button.
Material-Design-Components...
Ist das das Neue?
Das sieht ja
sogar schon in der Vorschau grausam aus.
Und es ist alles
sehr rund beim Material-Design.
Was ist hier los?
Warum sieht das so kacke aus?
Was ist, wenn man... M2?
Gibt es M2 hier auch noch?
Not found.
Ja, das hier. Und dieses Hamburger-Menü.
Floating-Action-Button. Genau.
Floating-Action-Button. Das hier oben.
Das ist typisches Material-Design-Optik.
Das Hamburger-Menü.
Das...
So genauso. Das ist dieses typische
Android-Material-Design.
Diese stark kontrastreichen Buttons
und...
Up-Bar. Das Hamburger-Menü
oben links. Das animierte
Ein- und Ausfaden, wenn man da draufklickt.
Das Sucher-Icon.
Das ist so diese typische Material-Design-Optik.
Und ich mag...
Ich kann der Sache gar nichts abgewinnen.
Ja, und solche Pop-Ups
und so.
Das... Genau so sieht das halt aus.
Das ist die typische
Material-Design-Optik.
Mit der App-Bar.
Mit diesem Dialog und diesen kontrastreichen Buttons.
Und dem Floating-Button unten rechts.
Maxi wäre ein
IP-Eingabe mit dem Date-Time-Picker.
Du meinst, dass
du dann auswählen kannst von 0
bis 255 und das ganze viermal?
Das wäre wahrscheinlich genauso
eklig. Das Ding ist halt...
Das ist
schön und gut, wenn man das auf Mobile
machen muss. Aber auf dem Desktop
kann man auch einfach was tippen.
Das ist meistens deutlich schneller, als in irgendeinem
Menü 250 verschiedene Optionen
auszuwählen.
Welches Design gefällt?
Hier gibt es da was.
Ja, immer wieder, aber
schwer zu sagen.
So...
Obviously, pick
das Twitter-Design gefällt mir.
Weil es was eigenes ist und gut
zur Video...
zu einer Videoplattform passt.
Ich würde zwar ein paar Sachen
ändern auf Twitter, wenn ich könnte.
Aber
alles in allem finde ich das Twitter-Design
echt nice.
Äh, nicht Twitter. Twitch.
Hört mal auf... Hört nicht auf mich, was ich sage.
Ich meine, ersetzt alles, was ich gesagt habe,
Twitter, durch Twitch.
Twitch-Design finde ich nice, nicht Twitter.
Twitch.
Als Videoplattform finde ich,
passt das auch mit den
Animationen, die sie haben, wenn du
den Chat anklickst, die Videos
anklickst und dann das Video-Fenster
oben bleibt. Ich finde, Twitch ist ganz gut
gemacht. Twitter ist auch ganz brauchbar.
Ähm...
Ich
persönlich, aber da bin ich wahrscheinlich
einer der wenigen,
die das noch gut finden.
Wisst ihr,
welches grundsätzliche,
nicht das Design,
aber welchen grundsätzlichen Aufbau
ich mag bei Webseiten
auf dem Desktop?
Das sind Webseiten, die
einfach auf dem Desktop sich
wie auf dem Desktop anfühlen. Zum Beispiel,
okay, Hacker News hat keine...
Ich sag gleich dabei, Hacker News hat kein
schönes Design. Aber
ich finde das
für eine Desktop-Anwendung
besser als
tausendfaches... Wobei...
Nee, ich zieh's
zurück. Die haben auch so was
ähnliches wie Endlos-Scrollen mittlerweile.
Nur, dass es nicht endlos scrollt.
Es ist auch schon ein bisschen
vermobilisiert. Aber immerhin.
Das finde ich vom
Ansatz her nicht schlecht, dass man sagt, ey,
guck mal, wir haben heutzutage Desktop-
Rechner mit 64 GB RAM,
fetten CPUs und alles.
Wir können mehr als fünf Zeilen
Text rendern auf einer Webseite.
Ich mag das,
wenn Webseiten sich auf dem Desktop anfühlen wie
Desktop-Anwendungen. Oder wie
eben Desktop-Webseiten.
Old Reddit ist auch
nicht schön. Machen wir hier Reddit
oder Reddit Frankfurt.
Wo bestimmt gleich mal jemand fragen muss,
ist es safe, zum Hauptbahnhof zu gehen? Das ist...
Ah, ich habe einen Biber gesehen.
Nice, nice.
Also, Old Reddit ist auch nicht schön.
Server-Side-Processing?
Nö, nö, nö, nicht unbedingt.
Ich mag Single-Page-Applications.
Zumindest zum Selbstprogrammieren.
Und allgemein
finde ich es nicht verkehrt, Sachen
kleinseitig zu machen.
Endless-Scroll und die Sachen
optisch überall
gleich anzupassen
für Mobile hat ja nichts mit
kleinseitig zu tun oder nicht.
Also das alte Reddit
fand ich auch ganz brauchbar.
Wenn ich da auch einiges ändern würde.
Wenn ich könnte.
Ich mag Webseiten, die sich halt nach
Webseiten anfühlen und nicht nach
Mobile-App.
Ansonsten muss ich sagen, Bootstrap könnte echt
schlimmer sein.
Vor ein paar Jahren
Äh
Hatten die nicht so eine Übersicht?
Get Bootstrapped
Vor ein paar Jahren hätte ich ja gesagt,
Alter, bleibt mir weg.
Bleibt mir weg mit Bootstrap.
Aber ich muss sagen,
ich finde die Bootstrap-Optik
gar nicht so
schlecht mittlerweile.
Das geht, ich finde
das geht voll klar, Bootstrap.
Was ich
vor ein paar Jahren an Bootstrap nicht mochte ist,
dass im Prinzip jede
Seite nach Bootstrap
ausgesehen hat.
Aber mittlerweile
ist es nicht mal ganz so krass verbreitet.
Das sind halt die typischen Bootstrap-Buttons.
Ich finde Bootstrap gar nicht
mehr so schlimm
mittlerweile.
Das geht schon klar.
Oh was hier, Bootstrap.
Ich finde das geht echt
klar. Also was ich
im Frontend
benutze als Frontend-Framework
ist in letzter Zeit immer Svelte.
Beziehungsweise jetzt in letzter Zeit habe ich auch
mir das Ganze mit Svelte 5 angeguckt.
Aber
ich kann mich noch nicht so richtig
festlegen auf irgendeinem UI-Framework.
Ich habe
viel, ich bastel, ich bastel
viel selbst, was immer Paints-Champ ist,
weil ich nicht der große
Design-Champ bin.
Ich weiß noch, wo wir mal irgendwie 45 Minuten
einen Input gestylt haben und es sah immer noch kacke aus.
Könnt ihr euch vielleicht noch dran erinnern.
Letztens, wo ich versucht habe irgendwie
so einen, so einen...
Was war denn das? Dropdown.
Dropdown mit Input zum
Suchen irgendwie zu stylen. Das ist ewig
gedauert. Nein, das heißt Svelte.
Das heißt nicht Svelte.
Das heißt Svelte.
Moment, ich kann, ich kann dir, ich kann dir
beweisen, dass das wirklich Svelte heißt.
Das ist der Erfinder,
das ist der Erfinder von Svelte.
Und jetzt lasst mal,
und jetzt lasst, lasst, passt mal auf, wie er Svelte ausspricht.
Ist die leise das Ganze,
hä? Warum?
Aha, wegen Mario
Kart ist das so leise.
Alright friends, gather round and let's talk
about Svelte 5. Hast du gehört?
Was hat er gesagt?
Alright friends,
gather round and let's talk about Svelte 5.
Svelte 5.
Nicht Svelte.
Das habe ich auch schon ausprobiert.
Ich habe auch schon Skeleton UI ausprobiert
und das letzte, das letzte, womit ich ein bisschen
rumgespielt habe, war
schätzen Svelte.
Wie auch immer man das richtig ausspricht.
Das war das letzte, womit ich
ein bisschen rumgebastelt habe, UI Framework
technisch. Und das fand ich vom
Ansatz her bisher das beste.
Nicht wirklich rein, also nicht wirklich
von der Optik oder von der Vielfalt an
Komponenten. Den Ansatz fand ich
wirklich nice. Und zwar,
dass es kein UI Framework im
klassischen Sinne ist, wo du fertige Komponenten
kriegst, sondern, dass
du, also auch wenn es Komponenten heißt,
sondern, dass
du im Endeffekt
Source Code
bekommst der Komponenten
in dein
Projekt und von da selbst weitermachen
kannst. Du bekommst quasi Base Komponenten,
komplett in Source Code und kannst es dann
customizen wie du willst.
Fand ich vom Ansatz her bisher
das von allem, was ich ausprobiert habe
am angenehmsten.
Dafür ist es nicht so vielfältig wie
manch andere Frameworks.
Ich habe vor dem Rennen gefrühstückt.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt schon wieder
Hunger, weil ich bin ja die Sache
wieder
los geworden jetzt. Lass mich mal kurz
checken, wie viel Kalorien habe ich laut
Garmin verbraucht. Lass mal kurz gucken.
Gucken was mein Garmin Ding macht.
Alter, kann mal bitte der
Widescreen Mode ausgehen.
So, ich habe verbraucht
Kalorien 882 Kalorien
sagt er.
10 Kilometer
1 Stunde 4.
Wie gesagt, heute war nicht sonderlich schnell,
aber anstrengend.
Genau das Gegenteil gefühlt von letzter Woche.
Ok, gucken wir mal.
Die BILD hat geschrieben
US Firmen warnen vor was?
Drogenstraßen in Deutschland. Da war Frankfurt
gemeint. Ah ja.
Ein Straßenplan mit Gefährdungsindikator
gezeigt wurde.
Naja, Nidderstraße und
Taunusstraße und so die Ecke da vorne
ist halt
berühmt berüchtigt.
In Frankfurt.
Mich hat View
bei dem Umstieg von 2 auf 3 verloren.
Aber da war ich wahrscheinlich noch zu Frontend Noob.
Weil
Svelte
3 oder 4 zu 5 jetzt
vollzieht ja
einen nicht ganz
unähnlichen Wandel
von View 2
zu View 3.
Zumindest von den
möglichen Styles
wie man das benutzen kann.
Also mit
Signals und
Runes nennt das
Svelte jetzt. Es ist recht ähnlich zu dem
was View 3 gemacht hat. Aber ich war
damals einfach nicht ready dafür.
Da war ich noch zu Frontend Noob.
Mittlerweile muss ich sagen, ich finde den Ansatz
von Svelte 5 richtig.
Und auch besser.
Weniger Magic. Umso weniger Magic
umso besser.
Die Leute sind natürlich ein bisschen am Flamen und sagen
Svelte 5 ist jetzt quasi wie React.
Es kann allein
schon nicht, was ich darauf antworten will,
es kann allein schon nicht wie React sein, weil du keinen
JSX programmieren musst.
Oder keinen JSX benutzen musst.
JSX ist ja der größte Faktor,
der mich persönlich an React
abschreckt. Ansonsten,
muss man ja klar sagen, React ist
mit Abstand das größte
Frontend Framework.
Aber JSX schreckt mich irgendwie
also mich schreckt generell HTML
und CSS
in JavaScript ab.
Was sagt ihr dazu Frontend
5 jetzt in meinem Chat?
JSX POC or not POC?
Oder allgemein HTML
in JavaScript
anstatt HTML in HTML.
Alles wird wie React
in letzter Zeit.
Das könnte man auch anders interpretieren.
Und zwar, dass React von Anfang an vieles
richtig gemacht hat.
Aber auch nicht alles, weil es wird nicht alles
wie React.
JSX lassen die meisten Frameworks
glücklicherweise außen vor.
Also es wird vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr wie React in den Punkten,
was React gut gemacht hat.
Okay Chatgear, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Was haben wir denn hier? WiFi 7 getestet.
Okay, was sollen wir uns zuerst angucken?
WiFi 7 oder
kein Pardon für
Parkshünder, der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister.
Und ich guck mir das nur an, weil der Chat
gemeint hat, Max, das musst du unbedingt sehen.
Der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister, okay.
CSS in JSX ist
mit Tailwind kein Problem.
Ist das nicht immer noch so, dass du
in JSX nicht class schreiben kannst,
sondern class name, weil class
ein received, äh, nicht received, ähm
restricted, ne
ein
Keyword von JavaScript ist ein
restricted
Keyword, ja.
Mir, du, dankeschön für den Sub.
Excellent.
Was? Heute passend zu deinem
Vater. Echt? Warum?
Es kommt jetzt ab.
Dating und Partnersuche, so arbeitet eine
Partnervermittlerin. Oh ja,
stimmt, hast recht, es passt zu meinem Vater, ja.
Weiß nicht, ob der, ob die
auch die Leute scammt wie mein Vater?
Eigentlich eher nicht.
Ich auch, ich auch.
Deswegen haben die mich auch bei
Vue 3 damit ein bisschen verloren.
Da war ich einfach nicht ready für.
Du kannst das nicht schon wiedersehen.
Ist das, ist das cringe?
Ich hab keinen Bock auf cringe Videos
jetzt. Ich hab keinen Bock
auf cringe Videos.
Oh MonkaS, ich hab
zu viel offene.
Ist cringe?
Oh, ich will kein, ich bin nicht
ready für cringe Videos jetzt.
Ich weiß, dass man das machen kann,
aber dadurch, dass die,
ja, ich weiß, dass man die Options-AP
noch verwenden kann, aber dadurch, dass die
die anderen Weisen so gepusht haben,
hat man sich als, sollte
eigentlich nicht mehr verwendet werden gefühlt in
Vue 3. Okay.
Okay.
Schau mal, okay, wir gucken uns das jetzt an.
Das geht ja schnell.
Niklas Matai ist 18 Jahre
alt und hat ein bizarres Hobby.
Weil er leidenschaftlich gerne
Falschparker jagt, nennt er sich
Wenn man sonst nichts zu tun hat.
Er ist heute
im Sachsen-Anhaltischen
Gräfenhainichen auf Streife.
Darf der überhaupt Polizei hinten draufstehen
haben? Wenn der nicht
Polizist ist?
Ich trau vor.
Vor Niklas ist kein
Parksünder sicher. Es ist Samstag
und in der gerade fußgängerlosen
Fußgängerzone wird ein Falschparker
Was, da steht nicht
Polizei? Da steht
Poliz...
Achso, da steht nicht Polizei. Okay.
Ja, dann ist...
Dann darf er das wahrscheinlich.
Ich trau vor.
Vor Niklas ist kein Parksünder sicher.
Es ist Samstag und
in der gerade fußgängerlosen
Fußgängerzone wird ein Fahrzeug
als Hindernis ausgemacht.
Das Fahrzeug parkt in der
Fußgängerzone und behindert dadurch andere
Verkehrsteilnehmer.
Wen behindert das jetzt hier? Wir wurden gerade behindert.
Wir sind ja da rechts hier gelaufen, aber wir mussten jetzt einen Schlenker nach links machen.
Warum machen Sie das?
Okay.
Es triggert mich aber auch, dass der Typ vorm
Hoftor steht. Mich triggert nicht
so sehr, dass der da steht, aber mich
triggert, dass der vorm Hoftor steht.
Ich muss mal erklären, was ist Ihre Motivation?
Um die Straßenverkehrsordnung
durchzusetzen.
Weil die Leute denken, die können parken, wie sie
wollen. Gerade jetzt zum Wochenende denken sie, es kommt
keine Ordnung an. Ja, who cares, man?
Dann kommen halt Leute wie ich.
Der Verstoß kostet 70 Euro.
Ich parke auch nicht vor meinem Tor.
Für eine spezielle
Falschparker-App bringt der
Hilfs-Sheriff das Delikt zur Anzeige.
Anzeige ist raus.
In dem Fall OAV 327-24.
Moment.
Das geht mittlerweile alles online.
Ja, Farbe,
Silber. Standort wird
automatisch erfasst. Und dann
Vergehen.
Schwierigkeit aus Fußgängerzone
kann ich eingeben.
Aber man muss schon sagen,
also nice da zu stehen ist es nicht, falls
da einer mit Kinderwagen durch will und sowas.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es Sonntagmorgen
und da ist halt nix los.
Ich denke, es ist klar, dass der da nichts zu
stehen hat.
Mir wäre es aber viel zu blöd,
rumzulaufen und überall zu
fotografieren und anzulaufen. Aber gut,
jeder hat seine Hobbys.
Der weiß Bescheid.
Die Anzeige wird automatisch erkannt.
12.54 Uhr festgestellt.
Die Anzeige geht um 13 Uhr raus.
Also gebe ich 13 Uhr ein.
Das Timing stimmt. Die Anzeige ist gerade raus.
Da kommt der Fahrer.
Ist das Ihr Fahrzeug?
Ja.
Das parkt in der Fußgängerzone.
Die Frau ist in Urlaub.
Ich bin gleich weg.
Das finde ich jetzt schon ein bisschen unangenehm,
die Leute da anzusprechen drauf und
hier auch wichtig zu machen.
Dass er das fotografiert und anzeigt, meinetwegen.
Das kann ja auch irgendwie den Leuten auf den
Sack gehen, ich weiß nicht.
Da hätte man aber auch auf dem Kirchplatz parken können.
Ja.
Da hat ihm jetzt schon ein Knöllchen gegeben.
Wie finden Sie das?
Da hat ihm überhaupt kein Knöllchen gegeben.
Hm.
Stehe ich da am Polster?
Ich denke, er war vom Ordnungsamt.
Das Ordnungsamt muss dann gucken, was es daraus macht.
Also da ist im Ordnungsamt der Unterschied.
Der Typ denkt sich gerade,
Alter, was willst du von mir?
Ich meine, manche versenden
ein Knöllchen, manche nicht.
Ihr habt recht, ein bisschen cringe ist es.
Das ist ja unterschiedlich, je nachdem, wie viel die zu tun haben.
Alles klar.
Dieser Herr ist übrigens sein Nachbar.
Doch Niklas kennt keine Gnade.
Schließlich hat er ein ambitioniertes Projekt vor sich.
Also mein Ziel ist halt, in jeder Stadt
und in jeder Gemeinde in ganz Deutschland
mindestens einen Falschparker angezeigt zu haben.
Jeder hat seine...
Und dann kommen Sie ins Guinness-Buch der Rekorde.
Kann sein, zumindest ein Deutscher.
Jeder hat seine eigenen Ziele.
Das ist eine Leistung,
die ich als Erster verbracht habe.
Na ja.
Heute sorgt jetzt...
Ey, ganz ehrlich?
Ich muss jetzt auch mal, wie soll ich sagen,
auch in so einem,
sagen wir mal, vielleicht etwas unangenehmen Fall,
das vertreten,
was ich schon an anderer Stelle gesagt habe.
Man kann
durchaus auf seine Leistung
stolz sein.
Ob das was ist, wo ich mich
mit identifizieren kann, sei mal dahingestellt.
Ja?
Aber es ist eine Leistung.
Das musst du erst mal schaffen.
Es wirkt schon ein bisschen super pingelig.
Es gab ja auch früher die Leute, die gesagt haben, ey,
Platz 1
in irgendeinem Competitive-Spiel online
zu erreichen, ja, ist keine Leistung,
weil es ist ja nur ein Game.
Man muss es erst mal schaffen.
Auch wenn das vielleicht was ist,
was ich jetzt nicht so geil finde, aber...
Zunächst...
Das musst du...
Ey...
Aber gut, jeder hat
so seine eigenen Dinger.
...in seiner Heimatstadt für Ordnung.
Im letzten Jahr hat er insgesamt
4000 Anzeigen geschrieben.
Bei so viel Engagement
drücken wir bei diesem Verstoß gegen
die Vorfahrtsregel mal beide Augen zu.
Der nächste Fall.
In der Gartenstraße steht ein Auto rechtswidrig
vor einer Dönerbude.
Ist das Ihr Auto?
Das ist ein Gehweg.
Oh, das, ganz ehrlich, das Fotografieren
und Anzeigen, ja,
aber dieses, die Leute drauf ansprechen
und so, das finde ich schon zu vieles Guten.
Ich habe gerade ihm Ware gebracht.
Ich mache gleich weg.
Ja, also ein- und ausladen,
halten dürfen Sie auch hier.
Ein- und ausladen, halten dürfen Sie auch hier.
Hier geht nicht?
Das ist ein Gehweg, darf er nicht.
Hier dürfen Sie halten.
So lange, wie es beim Halten bleibt,
kostet das 55 Euro.
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof hätten Sie
wahrscheinlich schon abgestochen, ey.
So.
Jetzt drücken Sie aber ein Auge zu, oder?
Nee, grundsätzlich nicht, nee.
Also muss er das Ordneramt gucken, was er daraus macht.
Wie finden Sie das?
Aber ich habe nicht ganz nachgedacht,
es ist vielleicht gerade 10 Minuten,
noch nicht mal 10 Minuten.
Ich kann noch meine Ware zeigen.
Hier ist mein Laden, ich bringe meine Ware.
Warum sollte das verboten sein?
Nö.
Der Typ macht ein Foto, legt das hoch,
der ist ja nicht selbst die Polizei,
der legt das hoch, das Ordnungssamt guckt sich das an,
verfolgt das weiter,
ist doch vollkommen okay,
Hinweise zu geben.
Da sehe ich jetzt kein Problem drinnen.
Das willst du bei anderen Sachen doch auch haben.
Ja.
Was ich eher blöd finde,
ist, dass er den Leuten noch zusätzlich
auf den Sack geht mit
wissen Sie denn, dass Sie da auch woanders parken können und so.
Das würde mich nerven.
Dieses Fotografieren und
Hochladen ans Ordnungsamt,
okay, ey, wenn er Bock drauf hat, soll er machen.
Die müssen ja auch nicht falsch parken,
aber die Leute nerven, das ist halt...
Oder außerdem,
Rico, ich wollte gerade was ähnliches sagen,
außerdem gehen mir auch Autofahrer genug auf den Sack.
Ich lade auf
und dann bringe ich zu meinem Parkplatz
mein Auto.
Dann wird die Lage dynamisch.
Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh,
jetzt geht's los.
Was geht jetzt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Wenn sie die Polizei haben wollen, kommen und die holen.
Ich nicht, nee.
Ich bin Privatperson.
Wie geht das jetzt weiter?
Ich rufe die Polizei.
Genau.
Boah, da hätte ich ja sooo
keinen Bock drauf, alter.
Ja, aber weswegen
wollen die die Polizei rufen?
Ich meine, das sollte ich
ihnen klar sein, dass es im Zweifelsfall für die
negativ endet, wenn sie jetzt die Polizei rufen.
Dann hat die Polizei
schwarz auf weiß, das Ding steht falsch.
Routine. Denn allein
in der 11.000 Einwohner Stadt
hat errechnerisch schon rund 8%
der Bevölkerung angeschwärzt.
Hier in Gräfenhainchen zum Beispiel
habe ich letztes Mal...
Ja, dass der vielleicht nicht ganz normal ist mag sein,
aber was ist schon normal?
32.875...
Wir sind auch nicht normal, Chat.
Und mit 902
Falschparkern. Oder 903, soja.
Ja.
Und jetzt haben wir übrigens ein Parken.
Aber sag mal so, dass Leute darauf ansprechen, finde ich
schon etwas cringe, ja.
Das Melden...
Warum nicht?
Wenn es einem Spaß macht,
zwingt dich ja auch keiner falsch zu parken.
Da musst du mit Rechnen gemeldet zu werden.
Das ist...
Ich meine, nix, was ich jetzt selbst praktizieren würde,
wäre mir die Zeit zu schade.
Aber dass die Leute darauf ansprechen, ich weiß nicht.
Das gibt es nicht.
Ganz offensichtlich keine...
Aber wie gesagt, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof würde ich das nicht machen.
Ausladevorgang, ja.
Dann kommt die Verstärkung.
Die kennen den Typ schon, oder?
100 pro kennen die den schon.
In dem Fall haben die ihn ja angesprochen.
Nee, der ist hingegangen, hat gemeint,
wissen sie auch, dass sie da vorne stehen können.
Niklas Matthei macht Meldung.
Hallo, Anzeigenhauptmeister und Matthei.
Hahaha
Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Oh, das ist schon ein bisschen cringe jetzt.
Es geht um den Falschbocker da drüben.
Ich habe ihn halt erfasst.
Und wollte halt letztendlich, dass die Polizei dazukommt,
habe ich einen Wunsch denen jetzt erfüllt.
Dann gehen wir mal zu den Herrschaften hin.
Unter dem wachsamen Blick des Anzeigenhauptmeisters
findet der Parkverstoß ein...
Der hat auch so ein bisschen salutiert,
gell, dabei bei Anzeigenhauptmeister.
...ein jähes Ende.
Niklas hat aber noch ein weiteres Anliegen.
Kann ich hier so lange so ein Symbolfoto vom Streifen machen?
Ja.
Rico sagt, ich finde das nicht mehr oder weniger cringe
als GTA-Roleplay.
Es hat ein bisschen was von GTA-Roleplay.
Ohne Scheiß.
Es hat echt was von GTA-Roleplay gerade.
So ein Symbolfoto, also so seitlich so auf dem Streifen machen.
Sie selber oder mit der Kamera?
Solange ich jetzt auf dem Foto drauf bin?
Ein kurzer Schnappschuss für die private Einsatzdokumentation.
Oh Mann!
Bei ihm steht ja auch Polizei vorne dran.
Nee, nicht ganz.
Da steht Polizphie.
Das was eigentlich im E normalerweise ist, das ist hier bei mir ein F.
Okay, ein bisschen einen Dachschaden hat er schon.
Aber wer hat nicht einen Dachschaden?
Der hat quasi ein eigenes Wort kreiert.
Was halt somit nicht mehr verboten ist.
Also verboten sind nur Hoheitszeichen,
also ich dürfte jetzt mal keinen Bundeswappen...
Also so ein Bundesadler oder sowas.
Naja, dass die Polizei an den Start gekommen ist,
lag an denen. Die wollten die Polizei haben.
solche hohe Zeichen dürfte ich halt nicht verwenden, aber der Schriftzug an sich ist
nicht verboten und schon gar nicht, wenn er halt abgeändert ist. Der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister
ist unterwegs zu seinem nächsten Fall. Eine Anwohnerin hat offenbar alle Fünfe gerade sein
lassen. Der parkt auf dem Gehweg und behindert dadurch andere Verkehrsteilnehmer. Was bedeutet
das? Okay Leute, kontroverse Frage an euch. Was findet ihr nerviger? Sowas, was der macht,
oder wenn sich Leute festkleben auf der Straße? Jetzt mal ganz wertungsfrei, würde mich einfach
interessieren, was findet ihr nerviger? Beides? Ja, okay. Chat, ihr seid pfeifert. Ich habe drauf
spekuliert. Ich habe gehofft, dass ihr schreibt beides. Und glücklicherweise schreibt ihr auch
zum größten Teil beides. Ich finde auch beides nervig. Es ist unterschiedlich.
Ich werde dadurch behindert. Kann ich da mal demonstrieren, dass die Behinderung verwirklicht
ist? Ja, wirklich, da hat schon ein Beamten-Deutsch drauf. Dann mache ich das nämlich immer mal ganz
gerne so. Stelle ich mein Fahrrad einfach ab, laufe ich jetzt als Fußgänger hier, muss jetzt einmal
drum rum ums Fahrzeug und schon haben wir die Behinderung verwirklicht. Das ist halt schon
eine Schöne-Kack-Position da zu stehen. So ist es nicht. Das ist die Behinderung dabei. Also,
ich würde mich da auch aufregen, wenn ich da vorbeilaufen müsste mit irgendetwas.
Keine Ahnung, wenn ich irgendetwas schieben müsste. Die Oma mit Rollator, den Einkaufstrolli
oder was auch immer. Oder vielleicht ist das auch ein Fahrradweg. Oder weiß nicht, ob das ein Fahrradweg ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist es kein Fahrradweg. Aber das würde mich auch schon abfangen. Ich würde den
Typ nicht fotografieren und hochladen, aber ärgern würde es mich auch, wenn ich da lang laufen muss.
Kostet 70 Euro und ein... Außerdem haben sie jetzt die Behinderung verwirklicht.
Klingt sich... Wie das klingt, Alter. Ist bei euch auch die Behinderung verwirklicht?
Punkt.
Wahrscheinlich hat die das gesagt, was sich so 90 Prozent der Leute denken.
Na ja, wo wäre denn das Problem, das Fahrzeug auf der Straße zu parken? Wie der da hinten,
der kann es doch auch... Hat der mal Arbeit und dann ist es gut.
So, hab ich. Hallo. Hakt's, Alter?
Apropos Arbeit. Niklas macht gerade eine Ausbildung im medizinischen Bereich.
Trotzdem treibt er mit seinem Wochenendhobby den Blutdruck von so manchem gewaltig nach oben.
Warte dich ab, du Vogel.
Es gibt eine Anzeige wegen Beleidigung.
Jetzt geht's ab. Direkt, direkt die Polizei rufen wieder.
Du Vogel. Ist das schon... Ist das schon... Ist das überhaupt schon Beleidigung, Mann?
Nach oben.
Warte dich ab, du Vogel.
Es gibt eine Anzeige wegen Beleidigung.
Bitte mach es.
Warte dich ab, du Vogel.
Ab. Jetzt stehst du auch auf dem Grundstück, also...
Ja, das nicht eingezählt darf man ja auch.
Der ist aber... Eins muss man ihm lassen. Eins muss man ihm lassen.
Der ist eiskalt bei der Sache, ja?
Den, den... Also weiß ich... Den schockt's überhaupt nicht.
Der ist abgebrüht, ja, was das angeht.
Wie gesagt, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof würde ich mir Gedanken um seine Gesundheit machen.
An den Knöllchen verdient er nichts. Eine Beleidigung ist da schon lukrativer.
Manchmal sagt er, beschuldigt er sich auch bei der Polizei aus. Ja, ich hab's nicht so gemeint.
Das ist noch ein eindeutiger Beweis.
Ähm, erhebe ich dann privatklare, also zivilrechtlich auf Schadensersatz beim zuständigen Amtsgericht.
Und dann kann ich damit abkassieren.
Warum er sich nicht beim Ordnungsamt bewirbt? Ich glaube... Keine Ahnung.
Der will das nicht hauptberuflich oder irgendwie...
Der will das einfach nur so als Hobby nebenbei machen, um sich...
Ich weiß... Keine Ahnung, schwer zu sagen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er da irgendwie hauptberuflich das auch verantwortungsmäßig machen will.
Er will einfach nur ein bisschen, wenn's ihm danach ist, seinen Rekord da.
Außerdem arbeitet er am Sonntag nachher.
Das heißt?
Naja, da gibt's vielleicht mal 50 Euro, mal 100 Euro, also so einen kleinen...
Und doch in dreistelligen Beträgen.
Weiter geht's. Die Nervensäge im Namen von Recht und Ordnung hat einen Volkswagen im Visier.
Oh, er steht falsch rum. Er steht falsch rum. Und ein bisschen zu dicht alles.
Der parkt auf der linken Fahrbahnseite.
Aber die anderen ja auch.
Aber andersrum.
Nee, die parken rechts. Und der parkt links.
Ja, das war ja offensichtlich... Das hab ja sogar ich erkannt.
Also Fahrtrichtung links. Die parken in Fahrtrichtung rechts, der in Fahrtrichtung links.
Er gibt sich aber nicht illegal als Polizist aus.
Nummer 112-042.
Auf die Frage hin...
Auf die Frage hin, gehören Sie zur Polizei, sagt er immer nein.
Warum machen Sie das? Stört doch eigentlich niemanden.
Bei Ihnen stört das.
Mit den 15 Euro können Sie vielleicht im Rathaus...
Ja, Bugelkuch, das finde ich auch. Der Reporter hört sich nicht sonderlich neutral an.
Es ist auch schwer, neutral zu sein bei dem Thema.
Aber zumindest als Kamerateam und der Typ, der da... Sollte man vielleicht ein bisschen...
Nicht so...
Vorwurfsvoll klingen.
Satchel Silva, danke für den Sub.
Zwei neue Glühbirnen kaufen.
Also kommt das auch der Stadtkasse zugute.
Dann, kurz vor Feierabend, gibt es für Matthei noch einen...
Oh, lässiger Lord. Nee, du, danke schön für den Sub. Ich habe ihn übersehen.
... im Lotto.
Oh.
Sieben Falschparker auf einem...
Sieben Stück! Jetzt ist er in seinem Element.
Bei dem kommt noch dazu, parken vor einer Burschenabsenkung. Das darf man auch nicht.
Auch nicht, wenn es die eigene ist?
Richtig, nach StVO, nein.
Der Grund, warum er die ganze Straße in siebten Haft nimmt, ist einfach. Mehr oder weniger.
Hier steht Verkehrszeichen 250, Verbot der Durchfahrt für alle Fahrzeuge.
Heißt, die dürfen hier nicht reinfahren, demzufolge auch nicht parken.
Das ist in dem Fall Parken in einem Verkehrsbereich, der durch Zeichen 250 gesperrt war.
Ey, ey, du musst es ihm lassen. Ahnung hat er. Zumindest klingt das so.
Bilanz der dreistündigen Streife. Zwölf Anzeigen wegen Falschparkens. Davon kann die Gemeinde jetzt eine Menge...
Darf man sein Rad auf der Fahrbahn schieben? Wahrscheinlich schon, ja.
... Glühbirnen kaufen. Ein neuer Tag im Kampf um die Straßenverkehrs...
Du darfst ja auch auf der Straße laufen. Würde man nicht unbedingt empfehlen, aber...
... Ordnung. Für den Knöllchenjäger geht es heute von Sachsen-Anhalt nach Niedersachsen.
Das Deutschlandticket macht es...
Er hat coole Outfits. Er hat ein gelbes Outfit, ein orangenes Outfit. Hat er auch ein grünes?
Sie sind ein Denunziant.
Naja, gewissermaßen kann man das schon so sagen.
Der Denunziant ist ja jemand, der alle anschasst.
Also wenn man das so aus der Perspektive betrachtet, kann man das halt schon so sehen.
Also wäre jetzt jedenfalls nicht verkehrt.
Und finden Sie ihn aber nicht schlimm?
Nee.
Warum nicht?
Naja, weil das letztendlich, was ich tue, kommt halt der Allgemeinheit zugute.
Das schadet zwar dem Einzelnen, dem Falsparker...
Neues Questgebiet freigeschaltet. Ja, auf nach Niedersachsen.
Aber die Allgemeinheit, die hat einen Nutzen daran.
Buxtehude, 11.30 Uhr. Der Helm sitzt.
Schon auf dem Bahnhofsvorplatz fallen dem Anschwärzer vom Dienst abgelaufene TÜV-Plaketten auf.
Oh, oh, oh.
Das bleibt nicht ungeahndet.
Das haben Sie so schnell gesehen?
Ja.
Kennt man doch schon an der Farbe.
Hier haben wir gleich den nächsten. Die ist seit November. Die ist schon im Moosegate-Bereich.
Was mich interessieren würde ist, wie viel von dem, was der ans Ordnungsamt schickt, wird dann letztendlich auch bearbeitet und folgt dann irgendein Bescheid draus?
Buxtehude scheint ein heißes Pflaster zu sein.
Also ich war auch schon in Gemeinden. Da habe ich eine Stunde gebraucht, bis ich einen ersten gefunden habe.
Und den habe ich jetzt drei in den ersten zehn Minuten.
Die Stadt, ein einziger Park-Sünden-Pfuhl. Genug zu tun für den informellen Mitarbeiter der Ordnungsmacht.
Nach nur wenigen Metern fällt ihm ein Verstoß nach § 12 Absatz 4 StVO auf. Macht 55 Euro.
Das steht auf dem Gehweg. Auf dem Gehweg darf man mit dem Kraftfahrzeug nicht fahren. Nicht halten, nicht parken, nicht drauf fahren.
Und wer sind Sie?
Ich bin Privatperson. Der deutsche Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Der deutsche Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Der deutsche Anzeigenhauptmeister. Oh, das klingt so schräg, Alter.
Ja, super.
Dann schreibt er vom Verein, wir sind die großen Denunzianten, oder wie?
Ne, den Verein kenne ich auch nicht.
Ja, da sind Sie aber offensichtlich drin involviert. Er ist ein Denunziant. Fertig.
Wir haben da unser Büro. Wir haben unser Büro da. Wir dürfen selbstverständlich hier kurz anhalten und Sachen da reinbringen. Das machen wir gerade in den Tisch.
Und er hat nichts besseres vor, als das zu tun.
Und zu фотографieren, mein Recht auf Privatsphäre, einzuschränken, dann rufen Sie jetzt die Polizei, dann klären wir alles.
Gut, dann machen wir das natürlich.
Die Leute sind auch schon doof, oder?
Warum wollen die jetzt die Polizei rufen? Das geht nur negativ für die aus!
Dann sieht die Polizei politicians lui vor Ort, dass der Fall steht.
Hallo? Können Sie bitte
Hallo
Hören Sie mich?
Ja, sicher
Ja, der ist Rechtsanwalt. Okay, jetzt geht es ab. Dann is er doch nicht richtig vernetzt.
Dann ist er doch nicht blöd. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Können Sie bitte einen Streifenwagen schicken?
Hier gibt es Streitigkeiten mit einem Falschbroker, den ich halt als Privatperson erfasst habe.
Und der ist nicht damit einverstanden, dass ich ihn erfasst habe.
Und da hätte gerne die Polizei dazu.
Das ist folgendes Problem.
Ey, die haben auch Besseres zu tun, oder?
Wir räumen gerade in unserem Büro ein paar Tische aus und ein.
Und jetzt kommt dieser Vogel hier an.
Oh, oh, Vogel direkt am Handy. Bam, Anzeige.
Da fährt hier offensichtlich sämtliche Autos hier an der Straße.
Und hat hier vorne an seinem Fahrrad so eine Bezeichnung Polizify.
Also er sieht so ein bisschen danach aus, als ob er so tut, als ob er Polizist wäre.
Der Betroffene ist Rechtsanwalt, aber über die Auslegung von Recht und Gesetz herrscht Uneinigkeit.
Darf der das?
Warum haben Sie das da dran?
Das ist scherzhaft.
Scherzhaft? Aber das, was Sie hier machen, das hat der Dame nicht zu tun.
Aber das, was Sie hier machen, ich habe den Eindruck, dass Sie das nicht scherzhaft meinen.
Das nicht?
Das meint er garantiert nicht, scherzhaft.
Das ist wieder scherzhaft.
Dann müssen wir uns jetzt aussuchen, was Sie scherzhaft meinen und was nicht.
Das schüttert ja damit.
Nein, ich glaube, dass Sie sich hier ein Maß anmaßen, was Sie nicht haben.
Aber das kann ja gleich die Polizei klären.
Da kommt sie schon.
Doch auch die echten Beamten sind offenbar nicht richtig zu erkennen, meint zumindest der Polizfist.
Uh, das Kennzeichen ist aber dreckig.
Er hat keine Gnade, Leute.
Keine Gnade.
Alle.
Der gibt gleich Anzeige für die Polizei, bei der Polizei auf.
Der ist eiskalt.
Das ist eigentlich nicht...
Next Level.
Das Kennzeichen müssen wir die auch mal sauber machen.
Das Kennzeichen wäre schön, wenn sie das nicht mal sauber machen würden.
Wenn das dann nicht mal lesbar ist.
Der pisst sich innerlich auch weg.
Der Typ.
Jetzt sag ich so, den Kennzeichen sauber machen.
Ja, müssen Sie jetzt noch nicht.
Jetzt geht das noch, aber wenn es noch dreckiger wird, dann kostet das auch irgendwann auch mal 5 Euro.
Das ist ein selbst kreiertes Wort.
Also wer da meint, dass das tatsächlich nicht echt ist...
Das steht auch nicht für die Polizei.
Nee.
Ist das keine Amtsanmaßung?
Überhaupt nicht.
Ach ja, und falls Sie mal auf der Ware Zeit haben...
Oh nein, ist das cringe.
Erzählt ihm jetzt doch bitte nicht, dass ich das nochmal schreibe.
Nicht, dass Sie das nochmal schön sauber machen sollen, oder?
Oh nee.
Das Kennzeichen wäre vielleicht gut, wenn Sie es euch mal sauber machen.
Also muss es doch nicht, aber wenn es dann immer weiter dreckig wird, sieht es halt so nicht so schön aus.
Wenn Sie mal Zeit haben.
Der ist ja wirklich gnadenlos, muss man ja sagen.
Zeit zum Putzen haben die Beamten ja.
Jetzt, wo Matthei ihre Arbeit macht.
Weiter jetzt.
Hase und Igel, die wuchste Hude.
Und auch Meister Petze ist immer schon da.
Also die dürfen wir nicht dehnen.
Und der noch dazu auf dem Gehweg.
Macht wie viel?
Mit Behinderung 70 Euro und einen Punkt.
Und der hat eine 8-Milo-Fluid-Tüftelkette.
Ich glaube, der ist so konsequent, dass er sogar sich selbst reporten würde, wenn er falsch steht.
Seiner Passion geht es schon seit drei Jahren nach.
Da kommt das zusammen.
Ich war letztes Jahr in 84 Städten und Gemeinden in Deutschland.
Und ich habe insgesamt für alle Städte und Gemeinden, wo ich war, 140.945 Euro erwirtschaftet.
Wie viel?
Für alle Städte und Gemeinden, wo ich war, 140.945 Euro erwirtschaftet.
Ja, und das hat eine Menge Geld.
Jeder, was er will.
Das ist nicht verboten.
Ich finde es auch ein bisschen cringe.
Außerdem zwingt die Leute, keiner falsch zu stehen.
Ich finde es auch.
Letztendlich total übertrieben.
Jemand, der sich kurz dahin stellt, was auslädt.
Ob das Ganze dann wirklich weiter verfolgt wird, ob da was kommt, weiß man ja nicht.
Aber verboten ist das nicht.
Nur im letzten Jahr.
Die Anzeigen kommen ja auch noch dazu.
Guck mal, das ist wie mit meinem Nachbarn.
Die stehen ja auch teilweise oft halb vorm Tor.
Das geht mir auch auf den Sack.
Aber ich gehe denen damit nicht auf den Sack.
Ja.
Und wenn ich mich mal irgendwo ein bisschen schäpp hinstellen muss.
Oder irgendwie im Garten irgendwas da über den Zaun hängt oder so.
Dann sagt er auch, okay, geht mir vielleicht auf den Sack.
Aber ich sage auch nichts.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es Leute, so ein bisschen wahrscheinlich wie er hier.
Kleine Story am Rande.
Bei uns im Garten wurde ein Baum gefällt.
Nach Anmeldung beim Forstamt.
Nee, keine Ahnung. Ordnungsamt.
Also wo auch immer man das anmelden muss.
Wir haben einen Baum gefällt.
Also nicht wir, sondern eine Firma war da, hat einen Baum gefällt.
Und der Baum lag dann da einen Monat rum.
Und dann kam eine andere Firma, hat den Baum klein gemacht.
Hat den Baum abtransportiert.
Und auf einmal steht das Ordnungsamt bei uns vor der Tür.
Und sagt anonymer Anruf.
Wir würden hier zu Zeiten, wo es nicht erlaubt wäre, quasi unerlaubt einen Baum fällen.
Und dann haben wir den in den Garten geführt.
Haben ihm das gezeigt.
Haben gesagt, guck mal hier, wir fällen den Baum nicht.
Der Baum liegt da schon eine Weile.
Außerdem haben wir die Genehmigung dafür gehabt.
Und dann ist er wieder abgedüst.
Also sprich, einer von unseren Nachbarn war ein bisschen drauf, wie der Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Hat bei sich aus dem Fenster geguckt.
Hat gesehen, oh, oh, bei Max im Garten.
Da wird an einem Baum rumgeschnippelt.
Zu dieser Jahreszeit darf man das eigentlich nicht.
Und hat dann beim Ordnungsamt angerufen.
Also Leute gibt es überall.
Für letztes Jahr, also für 2022 haben wir noch keine Statistik erstellt.
Mit der Statistik, das mache ich erst seit 2023.
Die jahrelange Erfahrung schärft den Blick fürs Detail.
Eine mit sieben Metern ausgewiesene Ladezone kommt dem Kundschaft der Verderbnis...
Ich fasse es nicht, Alter.
Der hat einen Zollstock dabei, um sowas auszumessen, Alter.
Oh Gott.
Oh Mann, Alter.
Fuck.
Also der ist wirklich gnadenlos, der Typ.
Wichtig zugepackt, Fuhr.
Wer nimmt lieber noch einmal Maß?
Das sind sechs.
Ja.
Also die sieben Meter gehen in dem Fall bis in etwa hierher.
Man darf garantiert Kreide malen.
Das ist erlaubt.
Ja.
Und die sieben Meter beginnen halt, wo das Holz steht.
Das habe ich jetzt vermessen.
Und das steht halt drinnen.
Genau.
Aber muss der Autofahrer dann den Zollstock dabei haben?
Muss er nicht.
Da muss er es nur gut schätzen können.
Hier in dem Fall hat er sich verschätzt.
Ja.
Genau.
Sieben Meter sind sieben Meter.
Kannst du das verschätzen?
Das kostet dem jetzt 25 Euro.
Also da steht ca. einen Meter im absoluten Haltverbot.
Genau.
Anzeige direkt raus.
Ca. ein Meter.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen kleinlich jetzt?
Ja.
Aber Gesetz ist halt Gesetz.
Ich wusste, dass die Antwort kommt, ey.
Dann steht da sieben Meter und nicht sechs Meter.
Ist auch egal, ob da jetzt hier so eine Pflastersteine sind.
Das spielt keine Rolle.
Das Schild geht.
Und das Schild sagt, das absolute Haltverbot geht nicht bis dahin, sondern bis dahin.
Der würde den auch bei zwei Zentimetern drüber fotografieren.
Steht da einen Meter im absoluten Haltverbot.
Jetzt noch schnell eine abgelaufene Parkscheibe aufschreiben.
Ja, da ist zwölf Uhr ange...
Dann ein Unfall.
Das Dienstfahrrad ist umgefallen.
Ist aber nicht weiter passiert.
Doch.
Ein Kratzer.
Oh nein.
Den Unfallort darf man nicht verlassen.
Das wäre Fahrerflucht.
Also ruft er die Polizei.
Okay.
Der ist wirklich...
Er ist hart drauf.
Dieses Mal in eigener Sache.
Hallo.
Ich hatte angerufen.
Verrückte Welt in Buxtehude.
Matthai wird wegen einer Ordnungswidrigkeit belehrt.
Und zwar von einer echten Polizistin.
Weil Sie den Fehler gemacht haben, haben Sie die Ordnungswidrigkeit begangen.
Das, was ich Ihnen vorhin erklärt habe.
Die Belehrung.
Das ist ja umgefallen.
Also...
Genau.
Aber Sie müssen dafür sorgen, dass das Fahrrad nicht umfallen kann, wenn es
umgefallen ist.
Ja, genau.
Das ist ja ungefallen.
Genau.
Aber Sie müssen dafür sorgen, dass das Fahrrad nicht umfallen kann, wenn es umgefallen
ist.
Genau.
Das ist ja ungefallen.
Also...
Genau.
Aber Sie müssen dafür sorgen, dass das Fahrrad nicht umfallen kann, wenn es umgefallen
ist.
Weil Sie sind verantwortlich dafür.
Ja.
Der Verstoß, der kostet 35 Euro.
Sie können das hier vor Ort zugeben.
Ich könnte Sie, wenn Sie eine EC-Karte dabei haben, hier vor Ort bezahlen.
Man kann direkt live bezahlen mittlerweile.
Ansonsten würde ich das an den Landkreis schicken und Sie bekommen Post.
Machen Sie das an den Landkreis.
Weil der Landkreis die zuständige Verfolgungsbehörde ist.
Ja.
Dann machen Sie das an den Landkreis.
An den Landkreis.
Ja.
Okay.
Danke.
Sicherheitshalber nochmal die Parkzeit beim Unfallopfer überprüfen.
Vielleicht hätte der gar nicht...
Vielleicht holt er die 35 Euro wieder raus.
Es müssen sich jetzt nur noch ein paar Leute als Vogel beleidigen, dann sind die 35 Euro
easy wieder drinne.
Ja.
Tصل.
Bilanz des Tages.
27 angezeigte Ordnungswidrigkeiten.
Kleiner Servicetipp zum Ende. Niklas Mattheis nächstes Ziel ist Passau.
Das muss man ihm echt lassen, der ruft da auch selbst an.
Gut, man weiß jetzt nicht, was gewesen wäre, wenn die Polizei, äh nicht die Polizei, wenn das Kamerateam nicht dabei gewesen wäre.
Glaubst du der Reporter? Ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Die waren zwar ein bisschen voreingenommen, aber das glaube ich, what the fuck, das glaube ich nicht.
Die Frage, ob es da überhaupt einen Schaden gegeben hat.
Oh man, der Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Was nicht alles gibt, ey.
Also ich muss sagen, am besten war, wenn man der Polizei erzählt hat, ihr Nummernschild ist dreckig.
Ja, und ihm geht es ja offensichtlich auch nicht darum, dass er irgendwie damit fette Kohle machen würde oder so.
Die Leute, es zwingt die Leute auch keiner falsch zu parken, aber klar, es ist schon sehr kleinlich.
Und eigentlich würde ich sagen, ey, lass es halt gut sein.
Ja gut.
Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Die kennen den doch garantiert alle schon beim Anrufen.
Mein Opa, weil wir es am Anfang von meinem Opa hatten, mein Opa hatte auch so ein bisschen, bisschen was davon.
Und zwar, immer wenn irgendjemand vom Haus geparkt hat, wohlgemerkt vom Haus darf man parken, hat er quasi Buch geführt.
Wie lang der da steht, also Buch, geistig Buch geführt.
Der hat, wobei, weiß ich nicht, ob der nicht wirklich einen Zettel vielleicht sogar hatte, aber ich glaube, der hatte keinen Zettel.
Ähm.
Mein Opa hat immer getrackt, wie lang stehen Autos oder LKWs oder sonst was vorm Haus.
Und er hat auch schon bei der Polizei angerufen, wenn irgendwie mal einer drei, vier Tage am Stück da stand, ohne sich bewegt zu haben.
So nach dem Motto, da steht einer vorm Haus seit vier Tagen und was weiß ich, was er denen erzählt hat.
Also da war er auch ein bisschen Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Aber nur, wenn es darum ging, dass einer vom eigenen Haus steht.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das ist beides.
Er hat so ein sehr...
äh, ausgeprägten, eigenen Ordnungssinn und ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass er schon ein paar Leute abfacken will.
Ja, was auch immer.
Verboten ist es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Und ganz ehrlich, es gibt auch Schlimmeres.
Das ist halt nervig, okay, aber es gibt deutlich Schlimmeres.
Gibt sowas in anderen Ländern auch, naja, ob es exakt sowas gibt, aber es gibt überall überkorrekte Leute, die, die wirst du überall finden, in irgendeiner Ausprägung.
Super korrekte.
Überkorrekte.
Überall.
Hast du die.
Okay.
So, was, was war das nächste jetzt?
Was hast du da?
Das da?
Äh.
Ich wollte mir, WiFi 7 wollte ich mir angucken.
WiFi 7 getestet.
Also ich bin aktuell noch bei einem WiFi...
5?
Access Point?
Glaube ich.
Moment.
WiFi, was hat die hier?
Ähm, 802.11ac ist was?
Das ist WiFi 5, gell?
An die High-IQ Netzwerk IEEE Standard Kenner.
Ist das WiFi 5?
Ja.
Das ist WiFi 5.
IEEE 802.11ac.
Da hänge ich noch aktuell drauf und ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme mit meinen Mobile-Geräten und mit meinen Microcontroller und Raspberry Pi.
Es funktioniert wirklich erstklassig.
Was aber auch daran liegt, dass das ziemlich gute Access Points sind.
Sollen wir mal einen Wettbewerb machen?
Ach, ist das die Seite, wo man reporten kann, wie die Leute falsch, wo die Leute falsch parken?
Der Bongo-Karl.
Moment, der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister ist nur auf Platz 2.
What's going on?
Nein, das Goat hits nix on.
Okay, lasst uns mal erklären, ob WiFi 6 taugt.
Äh, WiFi 7.
Die meisten Leute haben nicht mal WiFi 6 Access Points.
Ist WiFi 6 überhaupt schon offiziell gestandardized in allen Varianten mittlerweile?
Weil WiFi 6 gab es schon, bevor der Standard final war.
Gerade über WLAN.
Da gab es schon erste Geräte, die, bevor der Standard final war. Ganz weird.
An 3 Gigabit. Also 375 Megabyte pro Sekunde.
Ja, unter optimalsten Bedingungen zwei Meter vom Access Point weg.
Schaffen viele normale Festplatten nicht mal.
Und auch die meisten Kabel-LAN-Verbindungen nicht. Die erreichen nämlich auch maximal nur 1 Gigabit.
Das Schöne ist, das Schöne an Kabel ist, das Kabel ist immer gleich schnell.
Ja, auch wenn mal einer die Mikrowelle einschaltet daneben.
Und auch wenn der Nachbar noch ein paar Access Points hat.
Und auch wenn ich mich mal ein bisschen...
Wobei, das war jetzt ein blödes Beispiel, Max.
Ich wollte sagen, auch wenn ich mal ein bisschen woanders hingehe.
Ja, das Kabel ist gleich schnell, aber das Kabel kommt nicht mit.
Ah, hier ist wieder so ein, guck mal, so ein Tarnbomber.
Guter.
Die Dinger.
Die sehen echt aus wie irgendwelche speziellen Tarnkabinen.
Speziellen Tarnkappenbomber.
Wifi 7, der neue heiße Standard.
Wir haben sieben Geräte getestet, die Wifi 7 unterstützen.
Ja, und die Kleins müssen auch Wifi 7 können.
Und dabei natürlich auch ein paar Haken gefunden.
Außerdem erklären wir in diesem Video verständlich, wie genau Wifi 7 besser ist als Wifi 6.
Liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von Hostinger.
Hostinger bietet euch einen Website-Baukasten mit KI-Unterstützung.
Für alle, die schnell und einfach eine professionelle Website erstellen wollen.
Ob die Texte so professionell dann sind?
Ganz ohne Programmierkenntnisse.
In dem Paket ist alles dabei, was ihr braucht.
Domain, Hosting mit unbegrenzter Bandbreite, SSL-Verschlüsselung, E-Mails und der K...
Wetten, wenn da der falsche kommt, ist die Bandbreite gar nicht mehr unbegrenzt.
KI-Baukasten.
Da könnt ihr dann einfach hier auswählen...
Wobei...
Wobei, es ist ja nur...
Es ist ja nur eine Homepage.
Es ist ja kein...
Kein Linux-Server, wo ich irgendwie...
Was hosten könnte, was mehr Traffic...
...eine Website sein soll und sie kurz beschreiben.
Und schon habt ihr einen Entwurf.
Den könnt ihr dann nach euren Vorstellungen antasten und...
Okay, wir skippen das mal kurz.
Hier, das ist mein Handy, wie es bei mir zu Hause den Google Speedtest durchballert.
Bin ich ziemlich stolz drauf, dass ich hier so schnell unterwegs bin.
Okay, Moment.
Zack, Zack.
Ich mach's nochmal kurz.
Speed.
Oh fuck, hab ich gar nicht mehr installiert, die App.
Hm.
Ich bin...
Also, mein Internetzugang ist gar nicht so schnell.
Also, das...
Funzt gar nicht.
Ähm...
Speed...
Speedtest?
Was nimmt man da für eine App?
Nimmt man immer noch die normale Speedtest-App oder gibt's da mittlerweile eine bessere
für?
Ich mach das so selten auf meinem...
Also, ich mein, ich könnte einfach auch iPerf oder so benutzen auf dem Handy.
Bräuchte ich aber irgendeine Gegenstelle bei mir.
Okay, next, next, next.
Continue, continue.
Don't allow location.
Continue.
Not tracking.
Okay.
Reject all cookies.
Go.
Also, mal gespannt.
Ich hab 16, 16 Millisekunden Ping und nur, Leute, ich habe nur 86 Mbit grade, obwohl
der Access Point nicht weit weg ist von mir.
Die Frage ist...
Liegt es an mir, an meinem WLAN, an Vodafone oder an dem Testing, also an dem Testservice?
Ich lass es grad nochmal ausführen.
Naja, 85.
85 Mbit hab ich grade nur.
Na gut, ich hab auch noch einen alten WiFi 5 Access Point.
Kann ja schon sein, ne?
Mit 2,4 Gigahertz WLAN.
Okay, geht nicht schneller.
Das ist eine berechtigte Frage, in welchem ich mich befinde.
Das sieht man ja bei iOS nicht richtig.
Ist mir aber auch wurscht.
Ist Funst.
Weiß.
Weiter.
800 Mbit in der Sekunde.
WiFi 6 represent.
Ja, okay.
Ist ne Wahrheit.
Total.
2020.
Denn jetzt gibt's halt WiFi 7.
Oder wie wir...
Es ist doof, dass ich das auf dem Endgerät nicht sehe.
Kann man auf dem iPhone...
iPhone C check if...
2,4 Gigahertz.
5 Gigahertz.
Aha.
Open your settings.
Navigate to WiFi.
Das ist gelogen.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das steht da überhaupt nicht.
Ist das ne AI generierte Seite oder was?
Das stimmt nicht.
Das ist schlicht und ergreifend gelogen.
Das ist irgendein AI generierter Shit.
Das steht da überhaupt nicht.
Das ist...
Das ist irgendeine AI generierte...
Das ist kompletter Bullshit.
Ah, hier.
Okay, es...
Ich bleib dabei.
Es geht halt einfach nicht.
Super Fachleute sagen IEEE 802.11 BE.
Diese zungenbrechenden...
Ah.
Warum ist es jetzt eigentlich BE und nicht wieder A irgendwas?
IEEE Codes sind übrigens eigentlich die korrekten technischen Bezeichnungen.
Aber die WiFi Alliance hat sich als Marketingbegriffe diese...
Ja, das ist genauso wie...
Ich wusste mal aus dem Kopf, was ähm...
Äh...
VLAN war.
Einfach nur X oder so.
802.1X oder was war VLAN?
Ah, Q.
Q, nicht X.
Q, genau.
802.1Q.
Ja, okay.
802.1 war schon richtig, aber nicht X, sondern Q.
WiFi plus 0.
WiFi plus Nummer ausgedacht.
Also nach 6 kommt jetzt halt WiFi 7.
Kann man sich besser merken und kann man viel besser aus...
Ja, da sieht man mal, die machen das richtig.
Die machen das richtig, was die USB-Leute nicht auf die Reihe bekommen.
Sinnvolle Namen.
Ja, und dieses WiFi 7 soll in der Theorie, also auf dem Papier, unfassbare 23 Gigabit
pro Sekunde schaffen.
Aber nur bei Access Points mit 8 Antennen, das ist halt so Profi-Hardware für Konzerthallen
und sowas.
Für zu Hause gibt es nur Geräte mit 4 Antennen.
Die schaffen dann theoretisch 11,5 Gigabit pro Sekunde, was ja immer noch extrem viel
ist.
Aber Spoiler-Alarm.
In unseren Tests mit 4 WiFi 7 Basen und 3 Clients haben wir maximal 3,9 Gigabit gemessen.
Und das auch nur bei besten Bedingungen und kurzzeitig.
Dazu gleich mehr.
Erst mal ganz wichtig.
Was macht WiFi 7 denn nun genau anders als die Vorgänger?
Das aufregendste Feature ist auf jeden Fall Multi-Link Operation, kurz MLO.
Ihr kennt das ja vielleicht.
Auch wenn euer Router sowohl im 2,4 als auch im 5 GHz Band funkt, klinken sich eure Clients
oft in genau das Band ein, was gerade nicht am besten funktioniert und gehen da dann auch
ungern automatisch wieder raus.
Hier mal ganz vereinfacht erklärt.
Es gibt seit WiFi 6e drei Funkbänder.
Die nennt man umgangssprachlich 6 GHz.
5 GHz und 2,4 GHz.
Und je höher die Frequenz, desto schneller das WLAN.
Aber umso schlechter kommt es auch durch Wände durch.
Was leider auch gilt.
Je höher die Frequenz, desto geringer die Reichweite.
Wenn ihr also dicht dran am Router seid und keine oder wenig Mauern dazwischen habt,
dann solltet ihr 5 oder 6 GHz verwenden.
Seid ihr weiter weg, lieber 2,4 GHz, wenn ihr keine Verbindungsabbrüche riskieren wollt.
Bislang galt...
Das ist ja auch eines der Gründe, warum LoRa so weit weg ist.
Ja.
Weil es so weit geht auf 822 MHz.
Oder 822?
Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf gar nicht.
433 oder 868, genau.
422 oder 868, genau.
Leider entweder oder.
Euer mit dem Router verbundenes Gerät musste sich für ein Band entscheiden, auf dem es funkt.
Aber jetzt mit WiFi 7 und diesem MLO geht das erstmals,
dass zwei Bänder gleichzeitig genutzt werden können.
Und das ermöglicht nicht nur höhere Geschwindigkeiten, sondern auch eine bessere Zuverlässigkeit.
Und eine geringere Latenz, also weniger Verzögerung.
Leuchtet ja auch ein.
Das Ding ist, bis ich meine Access Points upgraden kann auf WiFi 7,
ähm, da werden noch ein paar Jahre vergehen,
weil die Dinger sind jetzt schon schweineteuer noch gewesen.
Weil es ja nicht jeden Tag 15 Kack-Noob-Endanwender-Access Points sind.
Und ich hab keinen Bock, 1500 Euro per Access Point zu bezahlen, wenn die neu sind.
Also muss ich noch ein paar Jahre warten.
Also wenn mehr Funkkanäle zur Verfügung stehen,
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit auch höher, dass gerade ein Funkkanal frei ist,
wenn was gesendet werden soll.
In der Praxis ist MLO aber ziemlich komplex.
Das muss auch noch ein bisschen reifen.
Also mein CT-Kollege Ernst Ahlers hat auch schon ein WiFi 7-Gerät getestet.
100 Euro für max. teuer?
Nein, meine Access Points haben gebraucht,
bei Ebay sogar um die 200, 250 Euro gekostet.
Die Dinger sind verdammt teuer neu.
... kein aktives MLO messen konnte.
Also es ist halt wirklich noch früh, es gibt wenig Hardware und häufige Firmware-Updates.
Wenn ihr übrigens genau wissen wollt, wie MLO und andere WiFi 7-Features funktionieren,
auf heise plus gibt es mehrere wirklich interessante Artikel dazu.
Der Link ist in der Beschreibung.
Also ich hab, genau, ich hab die Access Points aktuell.
Einen hier an der Decke gegenüber im Wohnzimmer
und einen unten im Keller an der Wand.
Da ist das komplette Haus inklusive Terrasse und drum herum alles gut abgedeckt.
Davon habe ich zwei.
Und um euch mal zu chocken, was dieser Krempel neu kostet.
...
Niemand, also ich würde mir das nicht neu kaufen, ja.
Deswegen sage ich ja,
die neue Generation wird dann das gleiche kosten.
Aber halt.
Aber was kostet so ein R750 aktuell?
Falls die überhaupt einen haben.
Gibt's doch nicht mal hier.
Oh, guck mal.
Nur 640 Dollar.
Die US-Variante muss man noch flashen, dass man sie in Europa verwenden kann.
Ja, und hier kostet...
Jetzt zeug ich die Schweine teuer.
Aber die haben halt sehr nice Features.
Warum sind die Dinger so teuer?
Weil das Enterprise-Geräte sind.
Die sind allein schon, weil es Enterprise-Geräte sind, teuer.
Weil das teuer sein muss.
Ich glaube, es gibt keine wirkliche so komplette Rechtfertigung,
warum die so viel teurer sein müssen.
Einfach, weil Enterprise-Geräte immer teurer sind.
Aber die haben ein paar ganz coole Features.
Für mich wirklich das Killer-Feature damals,
warum ich mir die gekauft habe, ist,
dass du unterschiedliche Passwörter vergeben kannst
für unterschiedliche Geräte.
Für das gleiche WLAN wohlgemerkt.
Also du hast ein WLAN, mein tolles WLAN,
und du kannst dort für unterschiedliche Geräte
unterschiedliche Passwörter vergeben.
Für das gleiche WLAN.
Das können mittlerweile die meisten Hersteller
mehr oder weniger gut.
Zumindest die bisschen teureren Hersteller.
Ich glaube, die Fritzbox wird das wahrscheinlich nie können.
OpenWrt kann das auch nur mit ein bisschen Gefuddel.
Unify kann es mittlerweile auch.
Da weiß ich nicht, wie gut.
Ich habe mein Unify schon eine Weile rausgeschmissen.
Aber das war damals der Grund, warum ich umgestellt habe.
Weil das einfach ein sehr, sehr nice Feature ist,
wenn man IoT-Geräte benutzt,
die man auch mal ab und zu wegschmeißt.
Ja, für IoT-Geräte zum Beispiel.
Stell dir vor, du hast eine China-Chinesen-Smart-Steckdosenleiste.
Die packst du in dein WLAN und die geht kaputt
und du schmeißt sie weg.
Dann ist ja immer noch dein WLAN-Passwort da drauf.
Was ist die Alternative?
Dein WLAN-Passwort ändern und dann auf allen 60 Geräten,
die es gerade verwenden?
Einmal durchbohren und fertig.
Weißt du, wo der Chip sitzt mit dem Speicher,
wo du durchbohren musst?
Ja, ja, ja.
Wir haben kein Browser-Add-on,
sondern ein TemperMonkey-Script gebaut dafür,
dass man noch ein bisschen besser Passwörter generieren kann.
Das ist halt wirklich nice.
Stellt euch vor, ihr habt ein Handy
und ihr wollt...
Das ist kaputt, ihr schmeißt es weg
und da drin ist ja immer noch...
Oder eine IoT-Klühbirne, ja, eine smarte Klühbirne.
Da drin ist ja immer euer WLAN-Passwort.
Genau.
Und wenn du jedes Gerät hast,
wenn jedes Gerät ein eigenes Passwort hat,
gehst du in das Webinterface, schmeißt das Gerät raus
und es hat keinen WLAN-Zugang mehr
und niemand kann damit was anfangen.
Das ist schon nice, wenn man viele Geräte hat im WLAN,
die potenziell auch mal weggeschmissen werden,
kaputtgehen und so.
Das löst halt das grundsätzliche Problem,
dass alle Geräte sich das gleiche Passwort sharen.
Das ist ein sehr nice Feature.
Es kann nicht die Antwort sein,
einfach was anderes zu verwenden immer.
So nach dem Motto, ey, ich hab keinen Bock auf Paint
und die Antwort wäre, warum nicht einfach einen Mac verwenden?
Der Angriffsvektor ist doch ganz offensichtlich.
Nehmen wir mal eine Glühbirne.
Die Glühbirne braucht ein WLAN-Passwort.
Also eine smarte Glühbirne.
Leuchtmittel, muss man da korrekt dabei sagen.
Das ist eine smarte Glühbirne.
Die muss in dein WLAN rein.
Also hat die auf ihrem Speicher in der Glühbirne dein WLAN-Passwort.
Die Glühbirne geht kaputt.
Du schmeißt die Glühbirne in Müll.
Und damit liegt potenziell dein WLAN-Passwort im Müll.
Für jeden, den es interessiert, auslesbar.
Den Angriffsvektor habe ich ja gerade beschrieben.
Der ist ziemlich offensichtlich, oder?
Jedes Gerät, was im WLAN war,
was du nicht mehr löschen kannst,
was du wegschmeißt,
hat potenziell dein WLAN-Passwort drin.
Wie wahrscheinlich das jetzt ist,
dass das jemand macht.
Da kann man sich jetzt überlegen,
wie hoch der Keck-Alu-Faktor ist.
Aber das ist ein bisschen wie
private Daten im Internet verteilen.
Oder Sachen verschlüsseln im Internet verteilen.
Alles, was nicht verteilt wurde,
kann keine Probleme machen.
Das ist da genau das Gleiche.
Der gleiche Grund, warum man seine Festplatten
verschlüsseln sollte.
Nicht, weil man Angst vor den bösen FBI-Hackermans hat,
sondern unter anderem, weil man seine Festplatte
auch mal wegschmeißen können möchte
und sicherstellen will, dass niemand,
der es darauf anlegt,
dort irgendwas auslesen kann.
Garantiert!
Und mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn es schon einige Angriffe gab
durch weggeworfene IoT-Geräte.
100 Pro gab es da schon Probleme.
Oder du hast deine Festplatte einfach
verschlüsselt und kannst sie einfach wegschmeißen.
Das sind alles ähnliche Szenarien.
Man macht das aus den gleichen Gründen.
Man schließt einfach Probleme
grundsätzlich aus mit sowas.
Es ist egal, ob jemand
das WLAN-Passwort ausschließt.
Es kann keiner mehr was damit anfangen.
Wie verschlüsselt man seine Festplatte am besten?
Veracrypt.
Wenn du Microsoft vertraust,
vielleicht auch sogar BitLocker.
Oder Linux, dann ist die Sache klar.
Ich mag Veracrypt für Windows.
Unter Linux ist es deutlich einfacher.
Da gibt es ja schon was eingebautes.
Und unterschiedlichsten Varianten.
Auf Datei-Ebene,
auf Block-Devices,
auf Webseite,
auf Internet.
Das kann ich mir
sehr gut vorstellen.
Dass es ein riesen
Sicherheitsproblem gibt,
wo vielleicht noch nicht so viele
dran gedacht haben bisher.
Ausgemusterte IoT-Geräte.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem.
Ne, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Das hat aber letztens schon irgendjemand gepostet.
Gucken wir mal das WiFi7-Video fertig.
Max, hast du das mit BitLocker mitbekommen?
Glaube schon.
Das haben wir sogar im Stream geguckt, oder?
Haben wir das nicht im Stream schon geguckt?
Da würde ich sagen,
das ist problematisch.
Aber das würde ich jetzt
tatsächlich nicht so...
Ja, das ist problematisch.
Sofern du ein Gerät hast
mit einem eigenen Chip.
Der Aufwand ist tatsächlich schon ein bisschen größer
und erfordert doch tiefgreifenderes
technisches Know-How.
Und du brauchst das Gerät
dafür. Aber das brauchst du
in meinem IoT-Beispiel-Fall auch.
Ja, das ist halt das Ding.
Ihr könnt euch denken, überall
wo was verschlüsselt wird
und automatisch
unlockt werden kann.
Irgendwo müssen die Sachen im Klartext drin stehen.
Anders geht das nicht.
Ja genau, sobald du
eine BitLocker-Pin oder Passwort
nicht automatisch entlocken machst,
dann hast du das Problem nicht.
Ich persönlich mag Veracrypt
zum Festplattenverschlüsseln.
Das ist auch mittlerweile von der Bedienung
Das kriegt eigentlich jeder hin.
Und dann musst du beim Booten
von deinem Rechner ein Passwort eingeben.
Und nicht nur ein Passwort, man kann das kombinieren
mit verschiedenen Methoden.
Es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeit
zwei Passwörter im Endeffekt
einzugeben.
Das eine ist das Passwort
und das andere ist, wie oft das Passwort
gehasht wird.
Aber
Veracrypt ist nice.
Das ist easy zu benutzen.
Aber jedem der Veracrypt benutzt,
dem muss klar sein,
oder sagen wir mal so,
jedem der ein Verschlüsselungstool verwendet,
ein gescheites
Verschlüsselungstool verwendet,
sei es jetzt Veracrypt unter Windows
oder eingebaute Lux-Geschichte
unter Linux
oder andere NGFS oder sowas
im Kernel, jeder der gescheite
Verschlüsselungstools verwendet,
dem muss klar sein,
wenn das Passwort weg ist,
sind die Daten weg.
Das muss einem klar sein.
Und das muss so sein,
sobald es eine Recovery-Variante gibt,
wo du nicht das Passwort brauchst
oder irgendein, ja wie auch immer
geartetes Secret,
ist das eine Kack-Methode
für Verschlüsselung.
Wenn das Passwort weg ist
oder wenn der Schlüssel, sagen wir mal,
wenn der Schlüssel weg ist,
dann müssen die Daten verloren sein.
Sobald du es irgendwie recoveren kannst,
ist es für den Arsch.
Deswegen war BitLocker bei mir von Anfang an
durch, weil das erste, was ich über BitLocker
gelesen habe, ist,
dass du irgendwie über Active Directory
und Microsoft-Sachen
vergessene Sachen
recoveren kannst.
Ja, das ist bestimmt nicht so allgemeingültig,
wie es sich damals gelesen hat.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Aber da hatte ich schon keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ja, oder wenn du TPM-Modul
in der CPU hast, ist das auch wieder was anderes.
Aber trotzdem, ganz ehrlich,
das Sicherste
ist immer noch, wenn ihr den Schlüssel
bei euch, also wenn ihr
den Schlüssel habt und sobald der Schlüssel
weg ist, dann muss das, Sgt. Silver übrigens,
sag ich schon für den Sub, dann muss es weg sein.
Anders, anders
taugt das nicht.
Recovery-Key in die Cloud, da weißt du schon mal,
dass das ein doofer Ansatz ist.
Ja, ein anderer hat auch gesubbt, du aber auch.
Oder nicht?
Ach, das war schon vor 44 Minuten.
Keck-Wait.
Ja, und die meisten Leute haben als Windows-Passwort
dann was, ABC oder wie?
Also,
wenn es um Datenträgerverschlüsselung geht,
Passwort weg, Daten weg, so muss das sein.
Oder Schlüssel weg, Daten weg.
Anders taugt nix.
Sogar 3 Monate
für den Heimpreis. Mensch,
das ist doch was. So, jetzt aber hier erstmal
genug Theorie, jetzt Praxis.
Im Test hatten wir die
Basisstation Amazon
Euromax 7. Entschuldigung,
ich hab meine gefährliche Roboterspinne
verloren. Hat die zufällig jemand gesehen?
Ich dachte Krabbe. Ein Asus GT
BE98.
Das ist was für Rust-Programmierer,
das Ding.
Da ist ihr WiFi auch blazingly fast.
Ein
Netgear RS700S
und ein
Zyxel WBE660S.
Ja, ihr habt vielleicht die eingeblendeten
Preise gesehen, zwischen
600 und 900 Euro.
Boah. Also, wirklich.
Ich sag, boah, mein Access Point
kostet neu einfach 1300 Euro, aber
ich kauf den ja auch nicht neu.
Und obwohl die Anschaffungspreise schon so heftig
sind, braucht man bei Amazon und
Netgear obendrein auch noch
ein Abo für bis zu
115 Euro im Jahr. Warum?
Warum genau brauche
ich ein Abo für meinen fucking WiFi-Router?
Was hast du für
Access Point? Ich hab einen RUCUS R710.
Zwei Stück.
RUCUS.
Um bestimmte Funktionen wie die Kindersicherung
oder dynamisches DNS zu nutzen.
Warum braucht man
ein Abo? Wollen die einen verarschen
oder was? Das ist mittlerweile
so lächerlich für jeden Shit.
Ich ziemlich doof, muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen. Ja. Und was man
auch noch bedenken muss, die vier Router
genehmigen sich alle
ungefähr 20 Watt. Auch ordentlich.
Auch ordentlich. Hat
8 oder so.
Die zieht nur 11,7 Watt
aus der Steckdose. Das ist schon
ein ziemlicher Unterschied. Ja, so, also das
waren die Basisstationen. Als Client
haben wir einmal die WLAN-Module
Intel BE200 und
Qualcomm WCN
7850 getestet. Das sind so
Steckkarten für den
Qualcomm WCN 7850
getestet. Irgendwie stimmen
seine Lippenbewegungen nicht mehr, oder?
Guckt mal. Intel BE200
und Qualcomm WCN
getestet. Das sind so Steckkarten
Irgendwas war da gerade verkehrt.
KI.
Also SSDs reintun.
AI-generated Video. Als dritten Client
haben wir einfach einen Google Pixel 8 ausprobiert
und erstaunlicherweise gibt es nämlich
schon ganz schön viele Android-Handys
mit WiFi 7 Unterstützung.
Bei Apple übrigens noch keine.
Und dann wurde hart getestet.
Mal die Frage an unseren Netzwerkexperten
Ernst. Wie hast du das denn jetzt genau
gemacht? Die neuen WiFi 7 Geräte haben wir
getestet, wie alle auch vorher, mit dem
iPerf3 Benchmark. Der erlaubt uns
ganz ohne Einflüsse über die Internetleitung
echte
Geschwindigkeit innerhalb des Heimnetzes
zu messen. Das geht mit zwei PCs,
einer ist der Client, der andere ist der Server.
Und wir messen dann eben auf
drei Funkbändern über
sechs verschiedene Positionen.
Das waren insgesamt knapp 400
Einzelmessungen, die wir zu den Ergebnissen
im Heft kondensiert haben.
Und das kam dann dabei heraus.
Den höchsten Durchsatz schafft die Kombination
aus Netgear RS700S
und Qualcomm WCN 7850
Client.
2682 Megabit
pro Sekunde aus
6 Gigahertz Band.
Am schlechtesten schnitt die
Kombination aus Pixel 8 und
Asus GTBE
98 ab. Nur 137
Mbit aus...
Das ist halt ein Problem, das hast du mit Kabel nicht.
Kabel wird
immer beste bleiben.
So ist es einfach.
Von der Latenz, von der Störungsanfälligkeit,
WiFi hat auch seine Vorteile, da wo man sich
bewegen muss, ja, mit mobilen Clients.
Aber es wird kein Ersatz für mein
Laptop PC werden. Außerdem ist es
ja nicht so, dass wir bei
Verkabelung irgendwie aufgehört haben.
Mittlerweile sind 2,5
Gigahertz immer normaler.
Äh, Gigahertz? 2,5 Gigabit
immer normaler.
Im Heimbereich. Wie sieht es bei euch daheim aus, Leute?
Wie sieht euer
Standard
Verkabelungsspeed daheim aus?
1 Gigabit? 2,5 Gig?
5? 10? Oder teilweise 40?
Gigabit noch?
Also bei mir ist es eine Mischung.
Bei mir ist es 10 Gig
und dort
wo es keinen Sinn macht, 1 Gig.
Ich könnte theoretisch 2,5
machen, aber
an den Ports,
wo es keinen Sinn macht,
macht halt auch 2,5
keinen Sinn. Also ich
hab beispielsweise mein Desktop PC
per 10 Gigabit
angeschlossen und ich hab
den
HP Server per Gigabit angeschlossen,
wo dann auch die
SSDs drin sind, wo du ein bisschen Zeug hin und her kopieren kannst
und sowas. Das ist per 10 Gigabit angeschlossen.
Drüben
beispielsweise ist Nvidia Shield
1 Gigabit.
Das kann auch selbst gar nicht mehr.
Der
Vergleichsrouter mit WiFi 6
schafft dir mit 162 Gigabit pro Sekunde
ein besseres Ergebnis.
Ohnehin sind die Messwerte natürlich
eine Momentaufnahme. Das solltet ihr
wirklich bedenken. So kam kurz vor
Redaktionsschluss ein Update des
WLAN-Treibers für den
BE200 raus und danach ging es in
Stichproben bei 6 GHz
hoch auf bis zu 3,9
Gigabit pro Sekunde Durchsatz.
Übrigens haben wir den BE200 auch
unter Linux zum Laufen bekommen.
Mit Kernel 6.5014
hatten wir keinerlei Probleme.
Der Qualcomm Chip lief
zumindest bei uns nicht unter Linux.
Mein Fazit.
Also ich muss sagen, dass ich mit WiFi 6
sowohl meine Internetleitung
als auch meine Festplatten
im internen Netz, also meinem
Home-Server, komplett auslasten kann.
Die Platten sind nämlich nur mit USB
angebunden und schaffen nur ein bisschen
mehr als 100 Megabyte pro Sekunde.
Da reicht ja schon Gigabit-Easy-Kabel.
Das entspricht 800 Mbit, also genau
das, was ich mit WiFi 6
hier zuhause auch hinbekomme.
Und auch meine 1 Gigabit
LAN-Anbindung, also per Kabel,
reicht für meinen Netzwerkspeicher-
Kram völlig aus.
Ohnehin ist hier ja alles mit einem
LAN angebunden, auch weil ich keine Lust
habe, mir neue Switches und so weiter
anzuschaffen. Und ehrlich gesagt,
ist das einzige Gerät, das 2,5
Gigabit per Kabel könnte,
mein Desktop-PC und
sonst halt nix. Also für höhere
Geschwindigkeiten brauche ich deshalb WiFi 7
nicht. Aber ich mache ja viel mit
VR und wenn ich PC-VR
nutze, binde ich zum Beispiel meine Quest
3 über WLAN statt mit
einem Kabel an. Und das funktioniert
zwar mit WiFi 6 schon
ziemlich gut, aber manchmal,
wirklich nur manchmal, sehe ich doch noch
so ein paar Artefakte. Mit WiFi
7 könnte das dann perfekt
aussehen. Und auch ganz
Da ist auch der Vorteil, dass es eben
sehr nah ist.
Da könnte, okay, in so einem Bereich,
ja, da könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das
sinnvoll ist. Allgemein
finde ich das sehr vielversprechend,
dass ich zusätzlich zu 5 GHz
mit WiFi 7 das
6 GHz Band nutzen
könnte. Und in diesem Funkband ist
in meiner direkten Nachbarschaft erst
schnell, oder? Wir haben jahrelang,
ja, 10 Jahre lang
oder so, haben wir, oder länger,
haben wir 2,4 GHz verwendet. Ich meine,
wir machen das ja immer noch. Dann kam 5
und jetzt ein paar Jahre später schon noch 6
dabei. Wie nicht los, ich habe das
also im besten Fall so ziemlich für mich
alleine. Ja gut, dafür könnt ihr auch auf
WiFi 6 eh umsteigen, aber
das hat ja kein MLO.
Und das würde ich mit WiFi 7
dann noch oben drauf bekommen. Und dieses
Multi-Link Operation hat ja noch
mal das Potenzial, Stabilität
und Latenz zu verbessern, weil
einfach mehrere Frequenzbänder
gleichzeitig genutzt werden können. Aber
ganz klar, die aktuellen Router
sind mir viel zu teuer. Und das
Ganze ist mir auch noch zu wenig ausgereift.
Außerdem kann mein aktuell genutztes Handy
noch gar kein WiFi 7.
Ja, warten wir mal ein paar Jahre ab. Aber sobald hier WiFi 7
fähige Hardware im Haushalt ankommt, da
würde ich... Also ich, ich werde WiFi
7 erst haben, wenn ich
gescheite Access Points finde, die
alle Features unterstützen, die ich haben möchte.
Und
das ist schon ein sinniger Preis.
Wie gesagt, aktuell, ich habe es ja gerade getestet,
bin ich irgendwo auf 80 Mbit gekommen.
Vielleicht hat sich das auch nicht in
5 Gigahertz eingewählt.
Keine Ahnung. Mein WLAN ist ja
das gleiche WLAN auf 2,4 und 5 Gigahertz.
Was auch immer mein iPhone da gerade
rumgespackt hat. Aber 80 Mbit
auf einem Handy
ist sicherlich nicht super krass
in der heutigen Zeit. Aber was kannst du
damit nicht machen? 80 Mbit
reicht halt für Internet surfen und
Videos gucken ohne Probleme komplett aus.
Selbst 4K?
Falls man das auf einem kleinen
Bildschirm sich geben möchte.
Muss ich mir da schon langsam überlegen.
Vielleicht in 1, 2, 3 Jahren. Mal
gucken, was es da so gibt und ob ich
da wirklich konkrete Anwendungsszenarien...
Linux-Distros laden. Ja klar, auf
das iPhone. Ja, das ist logisch.
... im Ärmel hätte. Also AVM
hat direkt 4 neue Router
mit WiFi 7 angekündigt, nachdem
der Fritzbox-Hersteller... Ich hoffe...
... ja, WiFi 6e... Nicht wieder mit
Huawei-Problemen. Oder
War-Way. ... einfach mal
übersprungen hat. Daran sieht man aber auch
schön, dass WiFi 7 nicht
gleich WiFi 7 ist. Denn
Pflicht ist nur MLO, aber nicht
das 6 GHz-Band. Also
man darf da WiFi 7 draufschreiben,
Oh ne, das erinnert mich ein bisschen
an USB-Standards. ... 6 GHz
können. So ist das zum Beispiel bei Fritzbox
5690 XGS,
6670 Cable
und 7682
sind alle
WiFi 7 zertifiziert, können
aber auch alle kein 6 GHz.
Nur das Topmodell Fritzbox
5690 Pro
beherrscht... Jetzt fangen die auch schon an
mit Pro dahinter, okay. ... alle 3
Funkbänder. Und das Gerät soll im Sommer
für 340 Euro
auf den Markt kommen. Funkbänder. Und
das...
Super Vectoring
35B, so so.
... Gerät soll im Sommer für 340...
Bin ich froh, dass langsam aber
sicher das Kupferkabel
den
Staffelstab übergibt.
Bei uns ist übrigens
immer noch kein Glasfaserausbau am
Start. Drumherum passiert aber
vieles, das heißt wir werden früher oder später auch dran kommen.
Aber aktuell passt's auch
so mit meinem Kabelanschluss,
wenn Vodafone nicht ab und zu rumspacken würde.
... Euro auf den Markt kommen.
Ja, wie ist das bei euch? Seid ihr jetzt schon
heiß auf WiFi 7 oder
juckt euch das alles nicht? Gerne
in die Kommentare schreiben und den
1003 Newsletter abonnieren und natürlich
hier auf YouTube den Channel selbst
und tschüss.
Ähm, äh, Fritzbox
wurde doch verkau... Ich hab nur ne News gelesen,
dass AVM
verkauft... Guck mal hier, das
ist Linux Mint und...
Alter,
dass es verkauft werden soll, ich weiß nicht,
ist das passiert? Wurde AVM verkauft?
Noch nicht,
oder? Das hätten wir doch mitbekommen.
Noch nicht, ja, noch nicht.
Was wird
uns denn empfohlen hier auf YouTube?
Nochmal, bevor wir jetzt hier durch...
durch Klicks hornen.
Keine Pumpe.
Der Auer.
Keckweight.
Ja, die bräuchte den Anzeigen-Hauptmeister.
Ehm, nix dabei, oder?
Die Partnervermittlung. Für mich,
ja, weißt du, ich hab's nötig, wieder
Dating und Partnersuche.
Ohne App, so arbeitet eine Partnervermittlerin.
Boah, ne, eigentlich hab ich da gar keinen Bock drauf jetzt.
Was ist das?
Apothekerin enthüllt Gehalt, viel Verantwortung,
hartes Studium, genug Geld.
Also, meine Erfahrung mit Apotheken
war eher, dass die Leute dort komplett planlos sind.
Es ist bestimmt wie bei
allem,
90% der Leute sacken halt
und das hat man dann im Hinterkopf, aber es gibt auch
durchaus ein paar Schlaue und Fähige.
Leute, ich hab übertrieben Hunger.
Da sollen noch ein paar Punkte
und ein paar Folgen kommen, nice.
Das war nicht schlecht.
Nächste guck ich mir auch an.
Was gibt's zu essen? Tja,
was könnte es zu essen geben?
Schwere Frage.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Es gibt zwei Varianten.
Es könnte Nudeln mit Lachs geben
oder Nudeln mit Tomatensoße und
Hackfleisch.
Gaks mit Fudeln.
Ja, das könnte es auch sein.
Aber ihr habt
natürlich Recht. Es gibt Nudeln
mit Lachs, korrekt.
So sieht das aus.
Ja, letztes,
es ist eigentlich ganz easy.
Letzte Woche gab's Nudeln mit Tomatensoße,
also gibt's heute Nudeln mit Lachs.
Eats.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Was ist eigentlich für
exzellente Five-Hat-Musik im Hintergrund?
Stream Ende.
Ja, und?
Ich glaube,
ich muss heute weiter MMO-Kreisel-Crime
machen.
Das Event geht heute bis 24 Uhr noch.
Sind schon alle wieder am Rumweinen.
Schlimm, MMO-Communities
ist das, nee, so spannend ist das für Leute,
die das Game nicht kennen, nicht.
MMO-Communities sind echt die Schlimmsten.
Die Leute sind immer am heulen.
Wegen
allem wird geheult.
So, ich geh jetzt was fordern.
Leute, wir hören uns bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.